James O'Keefe has given a speech to uh I
guess I don't I guess to staff at the
Veritas offices confirming that he was
removed from the CEO and from the board
he entered into the office and removed
his personal belongings that's what the
the reports are saying and project
Veritas has released a statement
accusing him of what appears to be
Financial malfeasance which I I do not
believe for a moment and one of the
things they complained about project
Veritas the board I guess accusing James
was that he used money for like funny
dance videos or events or something like
this and they called it like him
misappropriating funds well I want to
make sure I'm using this the care the
specific words they use but I'll just
put it this way I like that project
Veritas does dance events I like that
James O'Keefe is this figure is this
character that that brings life and and
a bit of levity to the to the work they
do and apparently that's not good enough
for the board so for this reason they've
removed him and are now I believe lying
about what's going on look man uh James
O'Keefe is the is the founder and CEO
project Veritas he's done tremendous
work the idea that Veritas can exist
without him is is laughable and so we're
going to get into this there's a lot to
go through apparently on Twitter they've
already lost around 140
000 followers people are just ditching
saying no way several major uh uh media
figures have come out saying I'm not
going to support project Veritas so
we'll talk about that
plus we got uh some other interesting
stories Marjorie Taylor green has
officially called for a national divorce
okay I mean there's an interesting
conversation to be had that one that
we've had quite a bit but uh you know
you guys ready to drink Civil War I
guess I don't know how you get a member
of Congress saying National divorce this
idea is expanding okay and more and more
people are talking about it and I know
people think that a national divorce is
some kind of peaceful thing but I don't
see how it can go any other way than
Civil War but hey maybe it won't be
civil war because the other thing we
talk about a lot is world war three
zelenski says that if China and Russia
team up it's World War III meanwhile
like I don't know everybody else is
already saying yo it already started 50
to 100 years from now when we're all
living in rubble and and nuclear
Wasteland we'll be like it all started
with the Ukraine and then Russia no
one's going to be waiting until Russia
team teams up with China
so we're gonna know that before we get
started my friends head over to
timcast.com become a member by clicking
that join us button and you will get
access to exclusive uncensored segments
from this show Monday through Thursday
at 8 pm we will have a members only show
coming up for you tonight at 11 PM you
don't want to miss it not family
friendly so tends to be sillier a bit
funnier but definitely not something for
your kids to have around
so don't forget to also smash that like
button if you're watching on YouTube
subscribe to this channel share this
show with your friends if you really do
like it word of mouth is the is the most
powerful thing you can do to help
joining us tonight to talk about this
and so much more is Steve Dace
happy to be here man I've heard a ton
about your show I've seen a lot of your
episodes especially in the last 24 hours
everybody warned me you guys like to do
snotty gotcha questions I freaking love
snotty gotcha questions why did you wear
that shirt anyway exactly because when
you wear plaid to hopefully distract
people from everything else that you
visually bring to the table see anything
you do to try to Corner me I will put
myself down even more so I'm ready to go
all right so so for those that don't
know you who are you what do you do I
work over uh at the place
um I'm you know when I was growing up
that one of the most coveted TV slots
you wanted was after cheers that's where
Seinfeld debuted news radio debuted
because after cheers was on I mean
you're gonna have to really suck not to
hold the audience right so I get to do
the show at the blaze after Glenn Beck
right so it's really hard to not be
successful you just get you know just
try to hold on to as much of his
audience as you possibly can and I'm
barely hanging on and so they were dumb
enough to sign me to a contract
extension for another three years back
in January you pull back a fast one on
those guys I did or or no one else
wanted the gig one or the two yes there
you go yes right on all right that
should be fun so thanks for joining us
you bet the blast we got Hannah hanging
out hi I'm Hannah Claire Brillo I'm a
writer for timcast.com you should
definitely follow Tim castnews on
Twitter and Instagram they are excellent
platforms to get your news from I've
heard I just want to point out I think
it's funny that you're wearing an
American flag yeah I'm really into
Twitter and behind you yes that's the
wood one this is the knit one I just
want you guys to know that I am
definitely from America don't question
Canadian yes
stop questioning my anchor baby life I
got problems no and one of them is the
military industrial complex maybe we'll
talk about that tonight Steve also
writer direct or uh I guess director
producer producers well executive
producer of Nefarious upcoming comes out
in theaters on April the 14th you can go
to the website who is nefarious.com we
actually pulled it off we made a right
wing horror film
they said it couldn't be done or maybe
no one's ever actually tried it before
we I think pulled it off we showed it to
some of your people earlier today and
man I got some really cool feedback so
who is nefarious.com is the website and
if you're gonna let me chill then uh
we've got a brand new book out rise of
the forthright confronting covet fascism
with a new Nuremberg Trial so this never
happens again we we fashioned this book
like a mock Nuremberg Trial we have
witnesses everybody's on the record we
have every interview recorded
whistleblowers from the Department of
Defense Health Care sector people whose
family members were medically kidnapped
or allowed to die in hospitals denied of
treatment this book is going to blow
your freaking mind and if you were not
already paranoid if you are not already
pissed okay if your blood was not
already clotting it'll be boiling when
you read this book oh wow all right we
got search pressing the buttons yo
what's up everyone surge.com ready to
start when you are let's jump into this
first store we got us from timcast.com
exclusive video James O'Keefe tells
project Veritas staff I've been removed
from CEO and board I have been stripped
of my authority as CEO and removed from
the board contrary to what any public
statements may say
he gave uh I think it's like a 45 or
around 45 minute speech and uh an
anonymous source provided this video to
us we uploaded it on YouTube and
published it and uh James basically
lines out he says throughout my 13 years
here our mission has evolved from Simply
being about exposing the truth with help
from some hidden cameras to something
more transcendental giving people hope
he says as I was going through this
process I reflected upon my appreciation
for so many of you what makes us great
is that we do this work because we
believe we have a passion and a flair
for storytelling he gave a big speech I
recommend you guys listen to the full 45
45 minute speech I can't uh break the
whole thing down uh in only a few
minutes but there are some things I want
to point out
the article says
timcast news has also been provided with
board minutes regarding O'Keefe which
included an indefinite suspension
without compensation and the funny thing
is maybe if we could I think um
it gets cut off right here we go this is
a an image that we received indefinite
suspension of Mr O'Keefe as CEO without
compensation what's strange didn't they
say before that it was paid time off now
we can see here in this document it's
not paid time off there's more
that uh in this image I think I think
this is uh this is I believe it's
something different let me pull this one
up indefinite suspension of Mr O'Keefe
from the board pending the results of
the two-dimensional audit so here's what
we have I mean so I just want to show
you here's the the full video you can
find at youtube.com timcast I don't know
if it was uploaded anywhere else I
believe the video of James given the
speech was leaked to a bunch of
different news outlets and uh I will I
will say this people are not having it
project Veritas on Twitter is currently
down 133 349 let's refresh and just see
what happens if it's the same yeah 1 133
585 followers have unfollowed them on
Twitter and we have this statement from
Veritas take a look at this this is
where it gets yeah I get the most
offended
here are a few examples of what has been
uncovered so far by PV leadership here's
the first thing I'll say James O'Keefe
is Project Veritas he started it he's
the one who paid the prices for it and I
assume most people are donating for him
to do what he does because they believe
in him they say fourteen thousand
dollars on a charter flight to meet
someone to fix his boat under the guise
of meeting with a donor sorry I just
literally don't believe it that just
sounds like nonsense and here's the
other thing I'll I'll tell you if James
didn't do the right thing and and or he
tried to by starting a non-profit if
James just did a private Corporation and
said donate money it's not tax
deductible and I can do whatever I want
with it nobody would bet an eye at James
O'Keefe getting a private jet not that I
believe that he would miss misuse funds
this way here look at this one sixty
thousand dollars in losses by putting
together dance events such as project
Veritas experience that I disagree with
those were not losses those those are
some of the most memorable project
Veritas experience exactly well also
doesn't Turning Point USA put on all
kinds of dance event stuff for students
like if non-profits lost money on one
thing but made it up in a different area
that's okay right they have to they're
not everything they're going to do is
going to be financially successful even
if ultimately it works out to be in the
green yeah these show different dynamics
of James and the crew the people he was
working with that it's not just some
stodgy news organization I think it
enlivened a lot of young people to get
involved because he's also an artist
Like A Dancer so I think that was
fantastic uh the use of funds the story
I I was just telling Ian we did an event
in New York with mines and James O'Keefe
was there and there's a there's a side
stage area it's kind of like backstage
and there's a group of there's a bunch
of people getting ready to go on and I
see James and I'm like James do a
moonwalk and then the whole room breaks
aside and everyone stands there as James
O'Keefe Moon walks perfectly through the
side stage that kind of thing in my
opinion I know maybe it's silly but that
is not a loss when James was doing these
videos he was making a character of
veritas that was something more than
just a hidden Newsroom that sometimes
posts viral Clips it was giving
character and personality this is
ridiculous I'm sorry it sounds personal
because if this was about money and he
cost the company a couple hundred
thousand dollars him leaving and all
these people believing like these are
the hardcore donors that are leaving the
last thirteen hundred and thirty
thousand people are the people that are
gonna throw ten bucks a month at project
Veritas that's 1.3 million the donors
already filed that cease and desist
letter right they said we want our money
back if you are getting rid of games we
are we gave because of him and so
therefore if that if he's not there then
this is not the organization can they
get their money back is that legal I
have heard some organizations do it
other times not I'm not an expert on it
uh it's it's an uncommon for plea for
people to be able to donate money and
then take it back so it sounds like it
would go to court I assume it sounds
personal it sounds like they some people
really didn't like the way James was
doing it and um because if they want to
or if it was about money then they made
a really stupid fiscal error in removing
James because he's a money maker to me
there's there's two consequences of this
that I think kind of even transcend what
your own views are of James and just to
go on the record I think the I think it
could be argued project Veritas is the
most and has been under his guidance the
most important information Outlet in
alternative media in the country
going back to you know their their
origin their Genesis with Acorn and
things of that nature and if I find it
fascinating as the guy that just wrote
about covet a definitive book about
covet fascism that somehow all of these
issues somehow immediately have to come
to a head after they just did the
ultimate sting operation on the demons
over at Pfizer the timing of that I find
incredibly not coincidental and I and
just real quick James he says this the
only thing that changed was the biggest
story in their history with over 50
million views and he said it's like a
10x increase over their other biggest
stories they've done so let's let's say
this but set aside him for a second in
your views of him and just look at
running an organization in leadership I
own my own company I own my own show you
got you own your show we have employees
we have organizations I've been a part
of presidential campaigns corporations
here's the reality of of those
ecosystems number one
um I hope they have lawyered up because
by that them even claiming these things
in disclosures they have not that
frankly the Biden feds need much of an
invite anyway they just do it on their
own but they've essentially begged for a
full audit of all their books from the
feds to come in and say oh okay you guys
have disclosed this then let's see what
else is under there and see if we can
just finish your organization off while
we're at it and then number two though
let's let's play devil's advocate for a
second and let's say there is some Merit
to maybe he wasn't kind that was their
previous story right he wasn't the
kindest boss now the story is some form
of malfeasance let's say there's a root
of Truth to them just for the sake of
Devil's argument
you don't take the Star Quarterback of
your team after he just won the friggin
Super Bowl and decide that Now's the
Time you want to have a conversation
with him about being a Kinder gentler
better teammate and and being a better
Steward of the team's resources he just
won the Super Bowl man hand him the
trophy let him take pictures and
celebrate that there were times before
that moment that you could have
addressed these things and there's times
later in the off season when there's not
as much eyes there's not as much
pressure where these kinds of things can
be addressed this is as you said in it's
either personal or or the the oversight
and Leadership and guidance of this
board is every bit as culpable if not
more so of what they claim James is
guilty of even if he's guilty of those
things how come no one stepped in before
this how come no one said hey you know
what now given we're at we're at a Next
Level here the level of eyes that are
honest the level of pressure that's on
us we've got to make sure we're even
more diligent than we ever have been
before no suddenly out of nowhere he
gets his b he scores his biggest gets
his biggest score in the history the
organization and now suddenly we want to
have a human resources review that is
some really crappy leadership on behalf
of that board even if they are telling
the truth yeah I think those are all
great points especially since uh project
Veritas as far as I know has their
non-profit status in New York and to get
out of New York you're at the will of
the attorney general which New York has
one of the most activist liberal
attorney general's Leticia James in the
country in my opinion I mean it puts
them in a terrible place as an
organization if the mission is so
important why would you do that and to
your point too like every circus needs a
ringleader and James O'Keefe is this
circus this ringleader to to kick him
off when you are kind of building this
huge momentum off of the Pfizer thing
seems like it's hard for me not to think
that there is something that James was
about to do that the board didn't want
him to that's not Financial James should
file
um I don't know what do you think LLC he
should immediately create something new
and it should be a for-profit
corporation and people need to
understand their that they a lot of
people think non-profit means charity
and goodness it certainly does not a lot
of a lot of these companies are just
they they exist to enrich people they
could be tax Havens you can run I mean
some of these some of these biggest
non-profits that you've heard of will
have like a 98 administrative cost ratio
and I think it's like it might have to
be at least 90 I don't know if they may
have changed laws but this means that
when you give a dollar 90 cents goes
into the pocket of the administrative
staff and 10 or less can go to the
actual cause that is and I've worked for
a lot of non-profits and I've seen some
that do 50 50 and even that's considered
really bad some good ones will brag and
be like 80 of your donation goes to the
actual cause and the administrative
costs are a reality of doing business it
just basically means that if they're
like save the dogs 80 cents goes to
actually rehoming a dog in 20 senses
paying the managers to file the
paperwork to re-home the dogs but when
you see one of these big non-profits and
you know their ratio is like 90
administrative yeah that means almost
none of your money is actually doing any
charitable work so here's what I would
say James should form a new company and
it should be a for-profit corporation
which means it won't be tax deductible
but there are enough people who support
project Veritas that he need only say
for 10 bucks a month I was just going to
say you get James O'Keefe's premium
behind the scenes directors cut you know
commentary on our stories and our views
and the news is always free so not not
too dissimilar from what we do with like
here's the free show yep I think he'd
make even more money and he'd then be
able to without question
wanted to get a private jet to go get
his boat fixed I gotta be honest James
deserves to have a private jet to go get
his boat fixed considering the risks
he's taken to his to himself and others
I don't think he actually did that
though that's ridiculous it's like oh
I'm going to meet a donor better have
the company book me a private jet that's
that's ridiculous so well maybe he met
with a donor who wanted to donate to
Veritas and did but also
got took his boat taken care of and the
same donor also fixed his book who knows
but this is but this is the thing too
like one of the claims they made I guess
in these internal documents is that he
used the money do they have that here
let me let me see if they have it here
something about
um like a wedding or something like he
used the money to pay for his wedding
and it's just like he's not married you
know and and apparently it was a venue
used for a corporate party they're just
taking things and twisting it to accuse
him of doing of doing things that are
wrong but I think Steve I think you you
put it perfectly
I would be more willing to believe this
if privately a board member hit me up
and was like look we're trying to figure
this one out what should we do to to
boot him from the company abruptly to
then publicly accuse him of abusing
employees and that note said some of
these signatories of this letter have
not witnessed or experienced any abuse
now they're coming out after uh the
donors refuted that saying well he was
misappropriating funds it's like I okay
you're lying it's a coup you're just
making stuff up it's also interesting
that you know he's off project Veritas
the nonprofit that we know about but
then he's also off of their uh political
action committee right there's the
project I don't remember what it's
called but it's a 501c4 which they're
allowed to participate in political
campaigns right as we're going into an
election year and who do you think is
like the most dangerous asset to anyone
in politics right now James O'Keefe
because he has such a reputation as an
investigative journalist I mean to take
him out of the organization right now to
me it it's deeply uh suspicious I care a
lot about James health and like just
personally I know him I like him a lot
and I'll spend times like being afraid
for my friends sometimes and being like
I don't want that person to get hurt I
feel like that about Obama too I was
almost like please don't but
don't don't go against the Deep State
Barack because they'll kill you but then
what happened was he just didn't go
against the Deep State and played ball
so like but I think James is just a guy
and the organization he created is an
organization of hundreds of people I
don't know how many people and they're
all from what I met a project those
people are fantastic and they do
incredible work I think it's like 65 or
65 people I mean they're they're putting
their lives essentially their
livelihoods on the line by exposing you
know corporate corruption and they can't
come back once you take this job it's
not like you can go back into the field
you're in right um it's a lot of them
are undercover so they're you don't know
who they are those people hopefully can
assimilate back in but you know if
you're gonna put your face on them on
the the movement but like I I think it's
important not to put all the weight of
this entire thing on James like he's
part of it and he will continue to be
part of the movement whether or not it's
with this company or another company
uh but I think it's the time to take the
heat off James's now like Veritas will
continue and it'll continue to expose
corruption and if they are corrupt
they'll get exposed
I don't know I don't agree I think Steve
you nailed it they them coming out
publicly and announcing Financial
malfeasance is
ask yourself who wants to there's an old
adage in sports you never want to be the
guy that follows the guy you want to be
the guy that followed the guy who
followed the guy right so the
organization just got rid of its founder
uh and its face and there really wasn't
another face because as you guys have
pointed out everybody else that is known
in the that has done public work has
done it undercover so he is the only
known face of that organization who
would right now given the amount of heat
that that is taking right now on top of
the open invite they literally just
hiked up their skirts and said that the
feds were open for business we showed
all the leg we've got all the way to the
panty line who wants to walk in there
and say yeah I think I want to take that
I want to I want to take that Dutch door
action I want to get screwed on the way
and screwed on the way out and I'm gonna
I'm gonna take over for a guy that's a
legend to his base and then at the same
time yeah the the people that just hired
me opened up uh and invited the feds to
come in for an investigation I think
that is probably a pretty small list of
people
Elon Musk
look at this year Revenue in 2020
Veritas brought in 22 million thirty
four thousand dollars I can only imagine
with this Pfizer video here's what I
think it's the money and and I'll tell
you why this some people are like I
think Pfizer came in and did something
I'm not so sure about that that would be
bad PR wise like you don't want to pour
fuel on a fire of a story by it I'll do
there's a story of these activists who
were protesting outside of McDonald's
saying McDonald's is bad McDonald's sued
them one and then their stock tanked
because the news reporting was that
massive Corporation attacks to private
individuals Pfizer's got to be like
everyone's cheering these guys on if we
go after them it's gonna hurt us Let's
ignore it here's what I think
2020 take a look at these numbers in
2019 project Veritas brings in 12
million 151 496 one year later they
nearly double their revenue to 22
million
how much money do you think is going to
come in now that they had the biggest
stories this biggest story ever in the
history of veritas I can only imagine
they're going to hit 40 50 million okay
maybe I'm maybe I'm I'm way off with the
40 was my first thought 40 right now
imagine you're on the board and you're
like
guys look how much money we have I've I
could never have and then James says we
are not using the money for what you
want we are going to use the money the
way I see it and we're going to do the
mission and I don't think the board
members necessarily are thinking I'm
gonna stuff my pockets but they're
saying something like let's use the
funds to build a new building and we can
start doing this and that and we can put
a gym there and then James is like we're
gonna do this we're going to do this
we're going to expose this you gotta get
rid of this is what I said when we first
got war that he was suspended if you
want access to the cash you've got to
get rid of the ideological founder who's
standing in the way of that big pile of
money now for them to come out with a
new excuse that you as misappropriating
funds it's it's projecting right it's
what we typically see from these
leftists they accuse others well they've
got board members posting their pronouns
in their Twitter bios and accusing
someone else of malfeasance and how do
board members get on board they donate
to the organization right so if you had
a year like this and again like I used
to work in fundraising
the the top amount of money comes from a
very narrow number of donors typically
right so I think yes they have really
great Grassroots support but there are
probably a couple new donors who saw the
work they have done and said I am
willing to really either scale up what
I'm giving or I'm willing to give a huge
donation for the first time now that's a
threat to all the other board members
right they are in potentially going to
lose their position if they are now
competing with these other high dollar
donors I think that this is a sketchy
thing to do especially when your
organization is uh doing so well has
this big story out unless you personally
feel threatened it seems like James is
uh intimating it's it's Pfizer he he
said the only thing that has changed is
that we broke the biggest story in our
organization's history during the last
week of January in 2023 with 50 plus
million views our video became a global
phenomenon he then goes on to add more
context and says that is the only thing
that has changed then suddenly an
unusual emergency happened just a few
days after the story he continued
and then he says on Thursday February
2nd I was informed by an officer of
veritas on the phone while enroute to
the airport that he would resign unless
I stepped down as CEO
can I want to address that the Pfizer
connection I gotta I got a question on
my show over at the blaze today someone
asked me why what would be Pfizer's
incentive to produce a product or any
product that could potentially be
harmful to its customers
when its customers are um you know are
people in in need of healthcare
you and I aren't Pfizer's customers
governments are
go no one within the sound of my voice
paid for a covet vaccine government's
paid for all of those you're not paying
for PAX Lovitt I know some people who
did pay for it uh they were doing like a
hundred dollar yeah yeah okay but but
okay in general in general yes
governments are being pedantic I know
but governments and that's all right to
be exact governments are the clients
what fight would he put out with that
video didn't put heat on Pfizer
they're indemnified going back to 1986
further in under Reagan further
indemnified by the perp act under uh or
other prep act under under Trump
the the heat's not on them that that
Haze in the barn they've cashed all
those checks
the heat is on the is on governments
people aren't calling Pfizer after they
watch those videos they know that that
nothing happens calling Pfizer God bless
there was a group of New Yorkers over
the weekend that did a rally in front of
Pfizer speaking my love language
chanting Nuremberg too Adam and that's
my love language but that doesn't do any
good the governments are the clients
Israel let Pfizer essentially experiment
on their population for an entire year
that's what our government did that's
what almost every major government in
the world did with Pfizer and moderna
they let their people be the real-time
human trial
in real time and possible and so when
when he puts that video out Pfizer the
the horse doctor Al borla at Pfizer he's
not sweating it governments are the
horse doctor yeah that's what he was he
was a worse doctor all right and and so
the veterinarian advisor is not sweating
it they're con the governments are the
governments are still somewhat depending
on what your views of elections are
somewhat still accountable to their
people in ways that the corporation at
Pfizer is not and that's a whole new
layer of heat and it's not just our
government people around the world guys
watch those videos and said hey why is
the German do you guys know what's going
on with excess deaths in Germany right
now they're higher right now than they
have been in the entire time of covid-19
they're higher right now in Germany 40
percent higher than normal that's higher
than they were at the peak of the of the
of the initial wave of covet in 2020.
how do we explain those things his video
opens up that entire Pandora
we'll slow down and go back and address
a lot of this stuff uh what's the name
Albert borla Albert borla and he he was
literally a horse he was literally a
horse doctor but hold on hold on you're
not being cute you're like no he
actually was treating horses
specifically yes so when they tried to
tell you that Ivermectin was horse paced
no it wasn't ivermectin's a Nobel prize
winning drug from 2015. it was
repurposed for animal use because of how
effective it was for humans we do that
with a lot of drugs by the way a lot of
our human antibiotics are repurposed for
animals all right well so he was
actually a horse doctor they're always
guilty guys they're always guilty
they're always guilty of what you accuse
you of so Trump's compromised by a
Russian p-tape it turns out Hunter Biden
is literally filming his compromise
videos with Russian hookers while
they're accusing that of they're always
always guilty of what they accuse you of
that's actually interesting because we
often talk about the Ukraine gate how
they accuse Trump of doing what Biden
actually yes but the p-type thing
actually is a good point too because it
was Hunter yes but no it's worst Pace
but it was actually he's actually a
horse doctor I wanted to point this out
because
um I don't know a lot of people probably
don't like Rick and Morty but you know
the mom and the show Beth is a horse
surgeon and they make fun of her calling
her not a real surgeon and she gets
really offended by it and it's just
funny that this guy is like a horse
doctor he's like not a real doctor like
works on horses but I don't know I just
wanted to bring that up anyway but uh
here's what I think I was gonna have
this question for you a few sentences
ago is that you talk about Nuremberg you
know your book rise of the fourth Reich
and all that
we we fed a lot of Libertarians come on
the show and talk about I don't know
where you end up on the on the economic
scale or whatever
I'm not entirely convinced that um this
is a problem that is completely free or
what could be solved by laissez-faire
capitalism or just straight capitalism I
think I think this is a problem of it I
think what happens is as much as I
prefer you know capitalist system over
say like a socialism don't get me wrong
I do think there's still an issue here
and of course the issue uh let's let me
slow down and walk through this because
I understand government is a problem in
this one here's the problem we face with
solving an issue like this
government mandates things because
they're lazy inept evil or otherwise
some are ideological and think now's our
chance we have you know lockdowns are
good for the climate and things like
that others are panicked and say well my
people are screaming do something they
don't care what I do as long as I do
something then Along Comes a big
pharmaceutical company who you mentioned
correctly the governments are the
customers the government says this is it
I'll take Public Funding we'll we'll buy
products from this this major
pharmaceutical and then it looks like I
did something the major pharmaceutical
says we don't care we're immune and we
have guaranteed government contracts so
it's a perfect storm of government
cronyism government corruption you're
describing fascism of course right and
ultimately what it is is the lucrative
merger of Corporation and state Elites
in the public and private sector the
classic definition what I see culturally
governmentally and and and in the
corporate system
I don't necessarily believe is
definitively mustache twirling villains
who are trying to destroy the planet I
know we've had many conversations about
population reduction about how you know
the New York Times I think I think it
was the times wrote that the lockdowns
the planet's healing now and that maybe
we need climate change lockdowns they
literally use the line from Avengers end
game when Captain America says well you
know after half the world was uh
disappeared the animals are back in the
Hudson yeah wow but I I kind of just
feel like it's more like a Jackson
Pollock painting than something as
precise as Rembrandt it is quite
literally the chaos of our cultural
Decay the system itself breaking down in
every different area that we've got
cultural collapse corporate and
governmental collapse that results in
nobody wanting to take responsibility
for the hard decisions and just saying
path of least resistance and leave me
the F alone and so we get all of this
mess I think it's I think it's all of
the above I I think that first of all
the number one issue at play here is the
spiritual and moral decline of the West
and you are watching a level of
spiritual darkness and malevolence I had
uh we had a private dinner with Tucker
Carlson out in Iowa this summer when he
came out to MC and event for us and one
of the questions we asked him was hey
what happened to the the bow tied
smiling libertarian who was friends with
Rachel Maddow on MSNBC and CNN and
thought frankly people like us you know
these dreaded uh you know Jesus Freaks
that we were the death knell of the
Republican party and we're going to be
the reason why you all never won any
elections how did you become our
favorite talk show host what what
happened with you because this isn't the
same guy that was on MSNBC 20 years ago
and he said something I thought that was
very profound and I think really does
sum up the era in which we live he said
you know I I'm a kid I grew up in
Georgetown Tucker said my dad was a GOP
operative everybody I was around were
political uh you know kids of
politicians or political operatives we
trick-or-treated together we hung out
together we went to school together we
did Christmas together I could see why
someone might think Medicare and
Medicaid might be the best way to help a
certain disadvantaged group of people
even if it my ideology doesn't agree but
I don't think that causes me suspicion
about your motivations he says what's
happened in this current ERA in America
and really throughout the West is
decisions are being made that no one
truly benefits from like we can disagree
vehemently you know ideologically about
affirmative action but somebody is
affirmatively benefiting from that even
if we think the the overall collateral
damage doesn't justify it you disagree
with that there is someone benefiting
from it no one benefits from kids being
sent off to the island of Dr Moreau from
meatballs surgery no one's benefiting
from that no one's benefiting from the
stuff that we're talking about right now
and he said when I analyze this as a kid
who just grew up in the in the
traditional political process and I and
I see people and I go to my liberal
friends and I'm asking why are you guys
doing stuff like this and they suddenly
don't have answers but they're just
going to do them anyway he goes That's
when I just had to realize that there's
a level of spiritual Darkness at play
here that's the only thing I can explain
when this level of nihilism and that's
what you just described him a
comprehensive nihilism whether it's
people's craving greed whether it's
their their they've given themselves
another group has given themselves over
to malthusian ethics at a nihilistic
nietzschean level okay of depopulation
whether it's all of those things whether
it's stupidity whether it's complacency
pour all that stuff in a cauldron add a
little dash of Newt an eye of bat okay
and a cup of water and boil it together
and pour it out and and what you see is
systemic decline of a civilization and
that's what we're living through right
now how do we reinvigorate Spirit like
Jesus tried but they just killed him off
and made a religion out of him and
they're like worship him now and it's
like dude he was trying to wake people
up to God how do we any time I've seen
in the past people try they get co-opted
and Cults get made out of them and then
they just the war machine moves on the
Roman Empire started a church well
here's what here's what I would say
no one remembers almost any of the names
of the Roman War Machine
everybody still remembers Jesus name
we Mark time by the way we we Mark time
human civilizations Mark time by the
birth and death of Christ all right the
most the the most attended worship event
in the of the year in human civilization
for going on a second Epoch is the is
the is the marking of the resurrection
of Christ followed only by the marking
of the birth of Christ so I would argue
his legacy is very intact when it's
those of people like me who believe that
he is God that he was resurrected and
the the testimonies that we have of the
changes that have gone on in our lives
and then we have gone on and helped
other people and do things that are
beyond our normal capability so we don't
give ourselves over to the nihilism that
Tim talks about I would argue his legacy
is intact all the people that put him to
death they're all in the ground all
right nobody cares about any of them but
Christ is still exalted and hailed and
worshiped two thousand years later so I
think his legacy is in really good shape
I want to pull up this tweet from
Marjorie Taylor green
she says we need a national divorce we
need to separate by Red States and blue
States and shrink the federal government
everyone I talk to says this from the
sick and disgusting woke culture issues
shoved down our throats to the Democrats
traitorous America last policies we are
done
Stewart says but we get to keep the name
right and then Nicole Pearl Pearl Roth
says cool California can keep the tech
AG livestock Georgia can keep their
infant mortality incarceration rates and
the country's lowest wages
I find it interesting yeah you can see
it it's down here Michael malice I love
this topic by the way he posted the case
for American secession from Observer why
it's time to disunite the United States
Marianne Williamson did you just call
for a civil war does she know what
happened the last time a few States said
they wanted to leave it's a funny thing
for Marianne to say because like yes the
Confederates did say hey we're going to
leave and then the the union was like no
you're not and then sent troops down so
uh the funny thing is there many people
left Sarah Silverman I think she said
this a while ago didn't she said
something about a national divorce
I know she has talked about it I don't
know about Sarah Silverman specifically
but it's definitely something that comes
up University of Virginia did they have
a center for politics they did this poll
last last October and they found that
like 50 of trump supporters are in favor
of a national divorce or secession and
uh 41 of Biden uh supporters are also
like nah that sounds good we'll we'll
split up I mean it's it's a majority
opinion that both political parties seem
to hold which is kind of wild yes Sarah
Silverman did say maybe we should break
up but to divide into like two or three
countries so this is a this is a really
really great example of why we probably
are headed towards a national divorce
the fact that Marjorie Taylor green two
years okay actually I think to be fair
was it September September so a year and
a half
after Sarah Silverman calls for this
Marjorie Taylor green calls for it and
now Liberals are angry how dare you say
something that Sarah Silverman said a
year and a half ago actually bipartisan
right it's bipartisan and not only that
marjory's led to the party uh to me we
absolutely need a national divorce which
is why it'll never happen all right
because first of all as we just
discussed with the James O'Keefe story
we can't have nice things in the era in
which we live but I think
what we're up against won't let us go
I
you're dealing with Jehovah's Witnesses
that have tanks all right the the the
the the same thing that that has the
Jehovah's you ever have the Jehovah's
Witness comes to your door on a Saturday
and it's always on the best weather
Saturday of the year every time it's
like they plan it always it may just be
that they only go out when it's nice out
that could be it too and and see now I'm
the guy that pushes back because I'm
just that kind of douche and so I will
ask them questions like so let me get
this straight only 144 000 are going to
be saved oh yeah
well I Googled it and there's four
million of you
so maybe I'll need to settle this
argument amongst yourselves before you
bug the hell out of us tell me once well
only that money will be saved and
they've already been selected and I was
like so what are we doing leave me the
hell what am I doing leave me alone but
but it's that level it's Lyndon
laroucheon I'm in an airport Hangar
holding up signs about Margaret Thatcher
20 years after she's dead level of
zealotry that that the spirit of the age
that these these sorts of statists and
who am I talking about these are the
people that put their pronouns in their
bio and before they had that the Ukraine
flag in their bio and before they had
that they had their vax pass or their
their vax card in their bio and before
they had that they had their mask in
their bio let me show how virtuous of a
lemming I am to the spirit of the age to
the state that level of zealotry isn't
going to let you walk away they're here
to fix you
they're here to fix you and if you don't
think you need to be fixed you will be
made to care and the only reason the
tanks aren't rolling yet is because you
all own about 400 million guns if you
didn't the tanks would be rolling
already well they're working on that
part yeah and so they're not going to
let she's right when she says that but
any society that really needs that would
not be able to accomplish it either
because the divisions that exist once
not both sides are not going to agree to
peaceably walk away the when you come to
the brink when you're about to ruin as
much Freedom liberty and prosperity as
this country is about to flush down the
toilet that only happens because the
forces that have pushed us to this Brink
are on some you use the word cult I use
that in my show a lot the level of
cultic zeal that says to hell with all
those things I have to win this argument
no matter what you cannot reason with
that that level of zeal will not let you
walk away let me ask you how many uh
countries have the freedoms guaranteed
that that we have like the Constitution
the Bill of Rights freedom of speech how
many others enumerated and itemizes us I
would argue none probably I think it's
probably close to none I think maybe
Liberia has something similar because it
was created by Americans or something
like that not that it's really working
out for him to be completely honest but
uh I have to wonder then if it is a good
thing for these bad people to see the
U.S break apart because it would remove
one of the only true free or close to
free as we can get societies and look
this has its problems it's not
completely free there's still uh
tribalism there's all these issues but
man I've been to some of these countries
been to countries where the cops will
just kill you and that's it the world is
not look I'll say watch Yellowstone have
you been have you ever seen that show
I've been watching it recently so I'm
gonna use it as analogies non-stop but
in this show they just kill people
you're in Montana you're in the United
States but you're still in the wild west
and they just kill people right you go
to other countries the whole country is
the Wild West you're in a city watch the
videos out of Brazil you ever see these
Brazilian videos dudes chilling in like
a grocery store and someone walks in
with a gun they start shooting at them
and then it's motorcycles pull up and
jump out and Rob you and then people
start shooting at each other I know we
have those things happen here too but
it's not that bad it's it's we we often
think things are way worse than they are
and some things are worse than other
countries don't get me wrong some
countries are nicer but I'm not going to
sit here and act like Sweden because of
its lower crime rate is better than the
us when the people in Sweden live under
a boot and are scared to speak up and
losing their jobs because their whole
country is woke the United States has a
lot of really awesome things going for
it but we're losing it and if people
don't speak up it's going to become bad
now as it pertains to National divorce
I think that the challenge is you know
someone super chatted that too much
blood and treasure was sacrificed for
this Union and that's an interesting
point
I know Michael malice I know Lou
gradkowski they talk about National
divorce and my the issue I have with it
is in the end it benefits those who seek
to subjugate the world because at the
very least it would split the territory
of freedom in half
the country breaks apart
then we know the blue States Go full
Canada and and then there's even less
freedom in the world it would be the
greatest breeding ground for limited War
the world had ever seen if the US were
to split in half it'd be one side would
be communist Chinese funded and then the
other side would be the remnants of the
United States or so how's that any
different than what we have right now
well bomber plans would be dropping
bombs on Tulsa Oklahoma you know like
annihilated cities that's why I don't
think it can be but this is
what you explained there a second ago
Ian is why people want it and then why I
think we can't achieve it
we we're talking we got people want to
Rattle Sabers about with China
what would a war between the U.S and
China ultimately decide the language the
social credit system will all eventually
go to is in that's really what we're
fighting for that's what it is that
would there would be no higher principle
other than do you prefer Mandarin do you
like Chinese hieroglyphics on your
social credit score or do you want it
accessible in English because every
major cultural institution in this
country either is already owned by the
Chinese or aspires to be like them and
so we're already in the dynamic that you
described that that Dynamic exists now
but the end result of seeing it play
itself out would also result in what you
are concerned about we are headed there
there's that's unavoidable unless you
start seeing great Awakenings what where
do we have Liberty in America to begin
with it's not a coincidence you had
Great Awakening spiritual revivals that
then led to Liberty in the country all
right and and that's why John Adams said
constitutions only for a moral and
religious people you can't have limited
government with people they think their
character has no limits upon it they'll
then eventually think I can do whatever
the hell I want and then make you pay
the bill and the freight for it when it
blows up in my face that's what we have
now called the welfare state So
eventually we're going to either see
Revival like we saw at the dawn of the
country or you're going to see the end
of the country and that's the path that
we're on right now this is a point of no
return what does Revival look like in a
modern sense like it is a return to
patriotism like how would you see
yeah a little picture well it depends it
has to begin with an acknowledgment of
the god that our rights come from do we
believe in God that's that to me when
when Chesterton said America is the only
country ever founded on a Creed that's
really what he meant that our rights
come and he was observing this as an
English Theologian a British Theologian
observing you know basically their
offspring and and how it had taken off
after the Revolutionary War period and
that was his observation is that America
took the the notion that rights come
from God the laws of nature and Nature's
God and therefore they're not bestowed
by governments and therefore governments
don't have the ability to take them away
and governments are just as accountable
to that same God as the people that
rights come from now we have civil
rights we don't have individual rights
we have group rights now uh we we don't
have a justice system based on
restitution anymore that's what stuff
like eye for an eye in the Bible means
doesn't literally mean eye for an eye it
means what you have taken from someone
else must be taken from you or you must
restore it there must be restitution we
don't have that now now you're now
you've committed a crime against Society
everything is centralized everything's
collectivist we see this in health care
that's why we had a that's why we had
covid fascism because Obamacare ended
the Last Vestige of the patient provider
relationship left in America men will
pay for Pap smears now you're all on a
community rating now everybody's a unit
now everybody's a file I mean if you if
dude go back and listen to Bob Seger's I
feel like a number from like 40 years
ago that's freaking prophecy on where we
are right now Californication by the Red
Hot Chili Peppers is really about
wokeism that's what that's what
Californication is is the is wokeism are
you saying about that in 2003 or
something what was you just reference
four years ago the Bob Seger's feel like
a number go look at go Google the lyrics
for that it'll read like prophecy of
21st century America one of the problems
of us all having rights given from God
that we founded the country on except
for those people those Savages they're
not even human they have no they didn't
even they weren't even human to those
people they killed the Native Americans
and slaughtered them and the black
people were three-fifths of a human uh
in the eyes of God according to the
founders so like yeah we say it's God
given us rights but like obviously the
history shows otherwise we slaughtered
ninety percent of the native population
that we didn't consider them human I
mean the people didn't even consider him
human at the time which is like the most
abhorrent thing in the eyes of God I can
imagine is that humans would consider
another human non like a a dirty animal
non-human and then kill it and say it
has no rights so how do we justify now
here's here's the challenge I think Ian
is that everybody projects and one of
the big mistakes people make when it
comes to any kind of historical Conquest
is the projection of your cultural
values under cultures that no longer
exist or have deeply different values so
I find this interesting in in in in
history the idea that all humans are
sound morally and that we should agree
with all of their ways of life like you
know the Aztec notoriously would
sacrifice people rip their hearts out or
whatever what they do they probably have
an altar and then like kind of open with
obsidian yeah and then and and while
they're alive and things like that so
you got to understand that being on
mushrooms even even deeply religious I
mean like the the colonial Europeans
were deeply religious and probably very
zealous in terms of their beliefs but
imagine how you would feel as this like
somewhat liberal libertarian type Modern
Man watching a bunch of people drag a
screaming woman upstairs and then Jammer
in the chest with obsidian and cut her
open in front of you you wouldn't be
thinking these are good people you'd be
thinking these these people are animals
oh my oh my God I mean not literal
animals you're saying that in a
derogatory sense like what is wrong with
these people I'm not saying every Native
American population was that way I'm
just saying what happens is young people
today look around at this society that
we've built Through Blood and sacrifice
blood and treasure for all of the death
thought along the way the Civil War
itself how many dead Union Soldiers to
preserve this Union ultimately leading
to the end of the Civil War not that it
was also the exact intention of the
Civil War but that was a big component
of it and then they say look at this and
say all societies must have been this
way and the contest conquest of such
must have been wrong and it's like dude
like that group of people was going
around murdering kids and raping women
non-stop yeah we all agree that was a
bad thing and they got conquered you
know are we at the point of History
where conquer and destroying is not the
way forward again now like are we truly
there no no I think no it's just being
it's done differently what you're living
in a post-christian America now and and
really a post-christian western
civilization so what will come next
exactly what preceded Christendom or
Western Civilization the Dark Ages
that's what will come next now these
dark ages the good news is you won't
have to worry about dying a Bubonic
plague because rats are crapping in the
street outside your home okay and that's
getting into the water table well we're
too advanced technologically this will
be a technocratic dark ages all right so
you'll it'll look like well frankly
China you'll have the accoutrements of
modernity you'll have a car it'll be
electric and they will determine from a
central Hub how whether it comes on or
not how far you can drive
um you'll have access to the internet
they will determine what you can and
cannot see and how often you can use it
you'll have a mobile phone they'll
determine you know who you can talk to
and monitor everybody else it'll it'll
be a technocratic dark ages all right
but it'll be a dark age for individual
liberty uh and and individual agency
nevertheless outside of the outside in
the history of the human species outside
of acknowledgment of a biblical
worldview on some level even imperfectly
there has never been any regard for
individual freedom and liberty in the 7
000 year history of recorded human
history period regardless of language
period custom culture it's never
happened outside of a Biblical worldview
because it's the only one that says men
and women are each made and the likeness
and image of God it's the only one that
ever has said that or proclaimed that
which is why outside of it it simply
doesn't happen we don't believe in that
worldview anymore which is now why we
went from feminism to now men are going
to become women now and become even
better women than the women were we
don't believe in anything Amer the West
is like the Joker but not the Heath
Ledger version at least the Heath Ledger
version wanted to prove a point we had
an argument that he were the Joaquin
Phoenix version we're the one that looks
at Robert De Niro and says I don't
believe in anything that's who we are
you know what the reason I have issues
with Christendom and well I I gotta I
gotta address that one the walking
Phoenix version is a combination of
mental illness and and anger at the
system
I think you're right the walking Phoenix
version of Joker is basically a guy who
doesn't understand what's going on and
is just angry and entitled so he kills a
guy who helped him let me let me stress
this because this is a really really
good point especially for those who who
know I love uh pop culture references
The Joker film
awesome you guys have all seen it Joker
you've not seen Joker no amazing film
okay and spoiler alert
I think it's the perfect example of one
they show all the protesters in the
streets screaming about about the 99
about the one percent smashing things he
Riles them up this Joker character in
the end they're like dancing and
cheering for him and that's basically
the idea is that he gets these followers
because he he kills this late comedian
saying you get what you deserve here's
the funny thing about it though
this is about a guy who's mentally ill
and he's up he's down in his luck he's
abused and then finally he snaps and he
kills some dudes on a train who are
messing with him and it's like you kind
of understand why he's so angry but he
really doesn't understand the system he
thinks Thomas Wayne's his dad he's not
he's crazy
he does a stand-up routine and he gets
made fun of for doing it because he
forgets his lines and laughs at his own
jokes
a late night TV show host puts that
video on TV and they all laugh at it a
true comedian at that point would be
like I did it They're laughing at me
I figured something out this is working
they're laughing let's let's roll with
it Roddy Dangerfield I was just going to
say how many great comedians have made a
routine out of self-deprecation and it
was it was hilarious and then you're
with them and so think about what this
movie represents with Joker he's a guy
who does something really funny that
everyone laughs at but he gets mad
because it wasn't the way they were
supposed to laugh so he goes on the show
when given an opportunity when they
actually say okay come on the show in
front of the world and decides to kill
the guy because they didn't give him
what he wanted because they didn't give
him his emotional satisfaction that's
why he's a bad guy and that's what I see
today with the wokeness with the
protesters they're mentally ill they're
unstable they're angry they're entitled
and they don't understand that our
founding fathers and our ancestors have
given them everything that's why they
hated the movie that's why the forces
were talking about it hated this film is
they they recognized it was the
Fulfillment of their own nihilistic
worldview this is where it goes yep and
then you get the uh right the Heath
Ledger Joker was trying to prove of a
point about he says if you know if I if
I told the news a busload a soldier
would be blown up nobody cares but if
you say a mayor dies and they'll lose
their minds and it's like okay well he's
actually got some method to his Madness
right Joaquin Phoenix really represented
in my opinion all of the wokeness
I was gonna mention Christendom which we
were talking about earlier and why I
think there's a problem why people are
having a problem with it and have hated
it for so long and want nothing to do
with it because it was used as a cudgel
used God as a as a as a constrictive
tool and if you didn't worship God the
way I Want You To Worship it then we're
going to execute you or
similar to what this Joaquin guy like if
they don't do it the way I want them to
do it so they would use it as a system
of control and you had someone like uh
Luther Martin Luther I think he said
it's between you and God it has nothing
to do with the church forget about those
the business the bureaucrats and uh they
try to kill him for that and so I think
people hate the business of of church
not that they have and they don't even
know what God is or understand the
emotions attached with experiencing that
vibration I completely agree with
everything you just said yeah I think
people are turned off by religion
especially you know very dogmatic
legalistic religion it can have very
negative consequences but it's hard not
to think that the other part is that
people don't want to have to be
accountable for themselves right like if
you have Christian there's morality or
things that are right and wrong you have
to hold yourself accountable to that
there are higher values you set your
eyes on the things above and if you want
to live an indulgent lifestyle here and
now and only think about what concerned
you today then why would you want to be
religious just right if your pleasure
comes from momentary satisfaction or
pursuing things that are wrong and bad
for your soul then like of course you're
you're not going to go to church of
course you're not interested and you can
say I think there are people who have
been harmed by you know exactly what
you're talking about but I think there
are also people who want to live for
their own pleasure and have no higher
moral conscience completely agree I mean
I I I'm going to be 50 this year and so
my generation gen xers we're the we're
the first post-sexual revolution first
porn generation mainstream porn
generation in America my mom got
pregnant with me at 15 actually 14. by
her High School senior boyfriend found
out over Christmas break of 1972.
um then January a month later we get Roe
versus Wade she's the originally the
cutoff was the first trimester she's
right at the cutoff she has time she can
go get an abortion her mom is twice
divorced five kids from two different
marriages living in the white trash part
of town that wasn't easy to do 50 years
ago let alone now okay
um she decides in the end she can't go
through with an abortion so she has me
at 15. we were on food stamps ADC all of
that she ends up marrying a guy out of
the Navy who came from a very abusive
background uh he was very abusive to us
physically mentally verbally I had a
hard time for many many years I didn't
become a Christian until I was 30. and
nor and most stats show if you're not
one by the time you you're 18 you're the
the odds you'll become one are very very
low why because a lot of times our first
Notions of God as a father come from the
father that we had in our own home and
if the father in our own home cannot
properly model that to us the older we
get the harder it is for us to grasp
that concept and so it was very
difficult for me to understand the idea
of an altruistic God it was very
difficult for me to accept that it was
very difficult for me to look at the
evil in the world and think that such an
altruistic being could exist it was very
difficult for then then of course I
liked the way I was living it didn't
want to change as you just pointed out
and then I realized there's a missing
component in all of this
we're all very anxious to question God's
character
when do we start questioning our own
when is the questioning of our character
begin
um and then you have to ask well who
Among Us has the wherewithal to judge
one another's character are you perfect
you you I'm not so then we all realize
no one's perfect so no one can judge our
character so guess then what we don't
have any more of character no one's held
accountable for every for anything and
so you have this systemic societal
collapse and that's and that becomes a
feedback loop and that's where we are
now and that's why I said we need
Revival we need to we need to remember
that there is a Creator there is a
better way than this and yeah you are
correct Ian we could sit here with every
world view and we could pick out a few
moments I mean
have you ever had your heart broken by a
woman before did you did you did you
Proclaim celibacy and decide always five
years yeah did you okay but are you
still a bit now no all right did you are
all women terrible because if you broke
your heart no but they were for like
seven years man and I I made a lot of
videos about my hate for women and you
were hurt yeah but eventually though the
need that you had for that companionship
for that intimacy eventually that need
went out did it not
say that one more time the need for that
for for companionship for for intimacy
that need that you had that desire went
out over the anger in the bitterness
that you experienced because of the way
your heart was broken right I think I
didn't I didn't know I couldn't sense
the need I was desensitized to the the
want of of a woman of of the connection
of a relationship or emotions for like a
decade and I almost killed you know that
was the end but then I just decided to
start over again and you know I would I
would encourage you I would encourage
you open up a Bible
just you and God one on one give God
that exact same shot
because a lot of the historical examples
you're going to cite are true Christians
Catholics and Protestants littered the
fields of Europe with blood post
Protestant Reformation for a century all
right our country figured out a way to
keep those forces at bay through the way
it with the things that Tim talked about
that were enumerated in the Constitution
that's what no religious test for office
meant you've got all these colonies that
are all founded by different vestiges of
the Christian church and literally if
you were a different denomination you
can vote or be a citizen in some of
these other colonies they figured out
ways to lawfully navigate those
differences but I would urge not just
you anyone within the sound of my voice
this thing is doomed unless more of us
get recreated with our con our our
creator and and I would I would urge you
just open up a Bible you and your
creator one-on-one and see if he answers
you know what's funny is that a lot of
Liberals are starting to come around to
this granted most liberals aren't but
there are disaffected liberal types who
I'm hearing I I don't want to call
anybody out but there are a few examples
of dominant classical and traditional
liberals who are saying I'm not
religious but I now recognize the
importance of religion Society maybe I
can give a shout out to at least one I
think James Lindsay has talked about
this there's a few others uh for me I
grew up Catholic so my family was always
to a certain degree a Catholic uh for me
though I kind of drifted away from it
but uh I've long talked about this and
and there was a period where I was like
I'm an atheist but the way I describe it
now is I didn't understand anything
about God when I was a kid because I
didn't know what people were talking
about didn't understand what atheism was
as a teenager because it was again just
people around me until I actually
started to read for myself and then
ultimately studying I was reading books
on physics and I was reading the
internet and trying to learn about time
and then I started to think about all
the things I learned in religious class
when I was at Catholic school and I was
like wait a minute and I started to see
a bigger picture here but I think
interestingly
what many people have talked about Peter
pogosian James Lindsay Helen pluck Rose
in their uh uh when they did the initial
Sokol squared how because I did a
podcast with them talking about how this
wokeness is a non-theistic religion it
is filled the creation yeah it's it's
filled the Gap absolutely yeah but the
issue is it is it is chaos to
traditional religion's order and I think
what you end up with is the one way I'll
put it this I'll put it this way the
stories I heard when I was younger about
Christians came from liberals and it was
I would describe as mostly
anti-religious propaganda when I
actually started to meet real
conservatives and Christians I was like
these people are nothing like they've
been described to me and ain't that the
story of the culture War we're hearing
right now absolutely Trump's a fascist
the far right they're evil they're
racist because they want to keep people
on one side of the fire correct and they
want to say there's a wall of fire Don't
Go Near it it'll burn you but on the
other side people are telling they're
good people and so I remember one of the
important stories for me was meeting a
friend I was in the suburb of Chicago
where it was more conservative and they
were pro-life and I'd never talked to
someone who was pro-life before and they
gave me very sound reasonable
explanations for their beliefs they
weren't too dissimilar to what my family
had said but they were a little bit on
the other side and I was like well these
are these are these are normal arguments
these are not there's nothing crazy
these people aren't insane like what was
all the stuff I was being told so now
what I think you see is with wokeness
you have have what I would describe as
just fire it is spreading it is a
chemical reaction it is a chaotic and
destructive force it's the walking
Phoenix Joker it's the walking Phoenix
Joker it's it's it's it's zombification
it's it's the zombie Undead version of
our culture of the things we believe
like racism is bad we want to get away
away from that we want we want equality
the Constitution guarantees it and then
you get this zombified corpse version
that's actually just infecting and
destroying the institutions that we're
actually trying to protect we want to
get rid of the bad stuff keep the good
stuff and build upon it it's just
consuming everything and destroying it
the most dangerous conversation in
America
is the one Ian and I were just having
that's the most dangerous conversation
people have some disparate views on very
and a very important topic but are
willing to sit down in a setting
publicly in front of other people and
hash them out and discuss them openly
share what's going with share their own
personal perspectives of what's gone on
in their own lives as to why they've
they came to some of the conclusions
they did or why they have yet to come to
those conclusions or took them so this
is this is how we actually come now and
reason together the wokeness religion
that you just described
everything that it does is to avoid this
kind of a conversation from occurring
whether it's about whether it's about
faith whether it's about ideology
whether it's about political parties
whether it's about particular issues
it's all to avoid this kind of
neighborly conversation that allows
differences to get discussed and hashtag
segue yeah and progress this because we
do have uh we have the story here from
timcast.com zelenski warns of world war
three if China allies with Russia I do
see an opportunity for China to make a
pragmatic assessment of what is
happening here I wanna I wanna I wanna
bring this up because for those who are
just tuning in or just jump into the
segment we were talking about religion
cultural Decay societal decay Joe Biden
the president of the United States
went on a surprise visit to Ukraine with
a 500 million gift
you know he could use 500 million
dollars people in Ohio people in Ohio
people in Flint Michigan project Veritas
care in America I say yes to project
Veritas but you know in all seriousness
um Pittsburgh's got a pipe problem yeah
how about we'd sprinkle some iron dust
into the rivers in East Palestine and
then put a magnet in there because what
happens is the oil coagulates around the
iron particles and then you can use a
magnet to get the oil out don't touch
your credit thundberg's going to just
kidding go ahead oh yeah
it's this simple yeah we're being warned
of World War III
says if China out of Russia we're being
told the world is on the brink of
Destruction
why would there be World War III if
China allies with Russia oh what he's
actually saying is because the U.S will
blindly and unapologetically give
Ukraine all the support that it ever
wants if China Russia team up yes the
U.S will fall in line behind zielinski
and go into an international conflict
between two superpowers or two world
powers Jimmy Dore was saying that how
zelinski is really falling in line
behind the War Machine and if he says no
we're gonna have peace that they'll just
kill him I I I I think so I'm just I see
this
world war three what if the U.S just
says no we're not interested in war not
over Ukraine what if Russia and China
team up and they say we're now going to
take Ukraine in the US went you were not
Ukraine have a nice day what he's saying
is the U.S will do what Ukraine wants
well especially since we've already
poisoned poised all of our citizens to
be obsessed with Ukraine do you remember
all the flags everywhere all the time
like we made this an issue that
apparently are especially
liberal-leaning voters are going to die
on right so if Biden backs out if he
says oh actually I'm going to cut off
funds then his base will turn on him and
be like how could you abandon them I
wish that were true I think they'll
actually just
oh great yeah okay then I I think
they're that compliant I think I I think
Joe Biden could do this camera and say
this is our new foreign policy fart
noises in the armpit and there and
that'll be the new that'll be their new
Avatar on Twitter tomorrow I've got a a
pair of Vans shoes they're blue with
like a yellow stripe on it and I've had
people be West Virginia colors or the
Ukraine colors exactly and I've had
people be like oh you know blue I'm like
ah come on man just choose West Virginia
forever West Virginia West Virginia
shoes this issue not weird with Ukraine
is my last nerve
and
and this is hard for me to say as a kid
who's a child of the of the 80s who grew
up in the we're America 80s who
wore Alex P Keaton monogrammed sweater
vests okay and and got up in the middle
of the night to cheer Reagan bombing
Gaddafi back to the Neolithic period
this is hard for me to say okay
you're taking my my high school age son
to fight and die in Ukraine literally
Over My Dead Body I'm never allowing
that I'm never letting you take him to
die for your Habsburg Dynasty World War
One needless 20 million pile of deaths
replay over your Elites pissing contest
not happening I don't care what the
threat is I don't care what the penalty
is and if you think you're drafting my
daughters get the camps ready because
you're gonna need them never happening
this is a this is this is an example if
history doesn't just repeat it Rhymes
this is a hat these are but these are a
bunch of Elites a little cabal that are
all throw Putin all of them all in
together this is a Habsburg Dynasty
pissing contest over a strip of land
most people can't find don't care about
has no strategic value to anybody within
the sound of my voice unless they're
involved in investing money with Hunter
Biden this thing is such a Croc it's so
fake it's so phony it's one of the most
simplistic disgusting stories I've ever
seen it's one of the most cynical
stories I've ever seen it's Wag the Dog
but dumber and and and and this this to
me is the final straw of just absolute
civil obedience we're never fighting
your damn War hell no I think it's such
pageantry I think you're totally right
it's all fake I mean the fact that
zelinski can come to our Congress and
not manage to put on a suit Joe Biden
goes to see him wearing a suit like he's
playing a character it's so bizarre he's
the only world leader on the brink of
War apparently or in the middle of War
who has to be in I guess camo or
whatever to convey to these people that
yes in fact we are fighting so much so
that he has time to do a Vogue cover
shoot with his wife I mean it's just
bizarre YouTube he's got time for
YouTube got time for you too he's got
time to make major public appearances
around the world via VIA Zoom I guess
he's not he can't leave his country but
it's all for show he has to continuously
say this is so drastic of course Lindsey
Graham is saying oh Mitch McConnell uh
with his Ukrainian tie the most
important Air Show and the country
as you're crying okay uh Lindsey Graham
Misty uh uh well I don't care about
provoking Putin of course you don't
because you don't have any sons you made
that lifestyle choice you don't have any
sons so nobody with your DNA Lindsay's
going out there on those battlefields to
freaking die for somebody's trust fund
or grift fund it'll be our sons those of
us who do have uh children they're the
ones that go out there won't be Hunter
Biden I mean he's tried to kill himself
with enough crack we all know that but
it won't be him doing it it won't be
their son's dying it'll be ours hell to
the no never happening shove it up your
ass we're never doing this but I think
you need more Americans saying stuff
like that I remember when my brother uh
he was a marine he deployed to
Afghanistan did any of us think we
should be there it was crazy and yet we
have we have been sending people to Wars
because we're we say they're supposed to
be there for a long time I hope that
Ukraine is a wake-up call right that
these are people who should not be going
that we're sending anyways for pointless
things but I just don't know that it
will be I hope it is I like that you are
likening it to the Habsburg Dynasty
which is like a family that was obsessed
with keeping the Germans and I don't
know the actually the literal history of
the Habsburg family they were all
married they were all related was that
where they had like the weird jaws and
like the deformities they were like east
of Germany were they like
Austria-Hungary and Hungary it was many
after a certain point it was just a lot
of people and they wanted in breeding
basis and they were trying to control
The Descent within Europe yes yep yep
maintains Germany so they like that the
Germans and the Russians are fighting
because if the Germans had won World War
One
what would have been different what was
World War nothing thought about not
nothing it was a pissing contest of
Elites my group of my wing of the
Habsburg Dynasty will rule over yours
wasn't it and that'll cost 20 million
lives well the only thing that came that
was the only good thing we did in World
War one is perfected freaking
distribution of mustard gas we didn't do
anything else
they're all related all the habsburgs by
the time we got to 19 by the time we got
to 1914 they're all related they this
intermarrying Within These Empires had
gone on for centuries they're all
related by the time we get there and so
it's just literally a it's literally a
playground across this draw Line in the
Sand cross this line your ass is mine
that's what we used to say when I was a
kid all right so they they the the
Archduke Ferdinand son gets or nephew
was it I think can't remember gets gets
assassinated they cross the line now the
other alliances come in across the line
before you know it now uh The Guns of
August have fired 20 million people died
from nothing all we did in World War one
was lay waste to Germany to give birth
to the Third Reich and the worst regime
that's probably ever existed in the
history of humanity was it like just an
arms development research program the
war under the guise of a war like we
want to see how our tanks fight against
our taxes as a kid born to a 15 year old
mommy and I don't know what it's like to
have so much of that inherent privilege
that after a while you're just like I
gotta fire off some of these rounds
because I can't just throw them away I
don't know the answer to your question I
mean my mom I was on food stamps as a
kid so I don't know the answer to that
question all I know is there is no if if
you look at traditional Christian just
War Theory this is not fighting and
dying for Ukraine morally is not a just
War period
I agree with that sentiment I well at
least from this perspective it doesn't
look like it I I think that he wants
Sebastopol the the trade port and that
he wants what East 105 that freeway
going down if we act like he's
going to want East 97 and East 105.
everything east of the denipro river but
I mean I don't see why Armistice isn't
the focus I'm not I am no fan of
Vladimir Putin I can't tell you how many
times Russia Today tried to book me on
their shows and I like never returned
their calls that all being said
Vladimir Putin didn't try to turn me
into an experiment for Pfizer and
moderna for the last two years right
Vladimir Putin didn't say by the way if
you did not consent to being a member of
said experience experiment you can't
work like literal like Mark of the Beast
you can't buy or sell stuff because how
the hell you got to buy or sell anything
you have a job all right so you can't
work I didn't say hey your family
business is non-essential that that
business that your family's had for 100
years that Family Farm it's not
essential anymore it's got to go we
don't even need to be so specific to be
completely honest if Vladimir Putin's
under the doorstep the Soviet Union
doesn't exist it collapsed and this is a
border dispute with Russia and Ukraine
that for some reason the U.S thinks it's
worth going to World War III over so I
agree there's sentiment we've got I
agree with that too the calls if you
look at our biggest problems I often say
to my audience on the blaze or my
Twitter feed the calls are coming from
inside the house all right the calls are
coming from inside the house we have
we've got we've got 90 you want to go to
war with China how about maybe taking
back control of your medical supply that
you gave them eighty percent of the
manufacturing we can't go to work dude
they're actually some of the they've
actually actually make some of our own
weapon systems where to award the
country that that makes all of our uh
all of our 80 of our antibiotics and
some of our high-tech weapon systems
that most of our Elites want to be like
Anyway the calls are coming from inside
the house the battle is here I've often
uh we've talked about this quite a bit
what would happen if China declared war
on the U.S right now if they said we are
officially Warring States back the F off
vitamin C antibiotics
skateboards would be gone people have no
idea how much of the standard products
we get are made in China and shipped
here
if China said we're at War and cut off
trade
what half of our box stores would be
empty you'd be like wait where I can't
get medicine anymore no no it's actually
made in China is that crazy they'd be
just as screwed so I don't think it
doesn't really make sense just just as
screwed I'm not so convinced oh yeah
good point look at the amount of
Farmland they own and they could just go
Stalingrad on us and just burn the
Farmland to cut off our supply chain I
mean we're in this position because the
great experiment of of
utopian progressivism globalism didn't
work and the reason it didn't work is it
ignores the basics of human nature and
this is this is how crazy the times have
gone when I got into this business 15
years ago Bill Maher was was doing
documentaries like religion religious
religious yeah thank you and I mean I
was doing whole shows debating him on
that now now I do shows where I play
clips of Bill Maher and affirmatively
quote him even though I'm not sure he's
changed any of his views and I know I
sure as hell haven't changed any of mine
but at least at least the old culture
War I liked the old culture War the old
culture War where people like me and
people like Mar debated we we both
agreed first of all that individuals
have some agency and human beings have
some rights of conscience
and the debates that people like me and
people like Mar were having is what's
the limit on that right of conscience
right he basically is by his own
admission a libertine he basically made
the McKee marquisite Assad argument if
I'm not hurting anybody else nobody
else's problem you know do what thou
Wilt that is the whole of the law that
was essentially his argument okay people
like me made the argument well there's a
little bit more to it because the one
that gave us our agency and the one they
gave us that conscience has a few rights
uh of of of limiting it that we need to
listen to for our own good and that was
the argument that we had is is did
people like me go too far people like
him go too far somewhere in the middle a
reasonable Society could emerge the new
argument now is you have no individual
agency at all you have no rights of
conscience at all and so this is why
without changing our positions on
literally anything this is why Bill
Maher and Steve Dace are saying a lot of
the same things right now because we are
both recognizing that old argument about
agency and conscience is out the window
we're actually having an argument
whether we have any agency or conscience
whatsoever are we totally Wards of the
state from the moment we breathe but
also I think Bill Maher started finally
paying attention to the news I think he
knew more than he was letting on for a
while and he just didn't want to say
anything because his audience is it's
liberals but he got to that point where
he's saying this stuff and he's like I
just can't anymore the issue and this is
exemplified by the Prager uh episode
where Prager said they're putting
tampons in men's room and the men's room
and Bill Maher laughed and the audience
laughed and everyone said no that's not
true and then bill was like that's for
their girlfriends what are you talking
about and Prager was completely correct
so I I think I think uh has has Bill
Maher apologized for that I think he may
have addressed it I think I talked about
it recently I can't remember but
what what we've been watching for a
decade Bill Maher has only started
paying attention to in the past couple
of years so I wonder if the issue is
simply all of those things you were
worried about 10 years ago in the old
culture War bill just didn't read
so he didn't know what he was talking
about did he really think that tampons
were in men's bathrooms to bring to
their girlfriends he when when Dennis
Prager brought up that he Dennis Prager
said if you claim a man can menstruate
you're a liar and everyone laughs and he
goes that's what they're starting to
claim and who and Bill's like who who's
saying it's like it's in the media it's
all over the news Google it just Google
search it you'll see it and then they'll
start laughing he's like they're putting
tampons in the men's room and then bill
goes that's for their girlfriends come
on no one's saying this and they're all
just laughing at him and uh of course
Prager was completely correct but Bill
Maher he's how old is he and he's sick
he's in his 60s he's not paying
attention to what's going on he has no
idea what's going on at these
universities he doesn't read the news
but he is now that's the wonderful and
yeah well maybe when his publicist came
to him and said hey they're calling you
a Nazi he was like what me they're like
yeah because you said these things like
what oh I bet he went because in early
2000s his show Politically Incorrect was
off the chain awesome and then it got
kick he got kicked off TV because he was
too hot for TV telling the truth about
the war machine he said what he said the
guys that hijacked the planes were
probably not cowards because that was a
brave thing to do to throw your life
away for something you believe in was
saying no you can't say that yeah well
then what happens is you go into
hibernation where it's like I I'm I just
got to pretend like everything's fine
and then finally you can't take it
anymore you gotta speak up he he got
older he's not consuming the the
up-to-date information on things like
I'm not gonna be able to come here and
tell you about the latest Tick Tock
Trend I don't know and in 10 years when
all of these young people who have built
up big followings on Tick Tock are not
talking politics I'm not going to see
what they're saying of course me
understanding that issue I try to have a
better connection to the the generations
concerns and the political Arena of
which right now as Millennials I'm
entering I'm in I'm mentoring the
entering mentoring the end of my third
I'll be 37 and about two uh two weeks
37. so uh for younger people what do we
do well we've we got you know you're
you're young ish I guess a token female
young person there you go we're bringing
young people and we uh we where we try
to pay attention know what younger
people are talking about but there's a
lot less younger people care about
politics and that's the way it tends to
be when Bill Maher turned 60 and
Millennials are now in their 30s
inheriting these systems and saying
raising kids of their own raising kids
having a perspective Beyond just their
own selfishness and seeing what schools
are doing seeing what they're teaching
their kids
they're talking about it you get loud
and Counting you get that fight and Bill
Maher in his 60s doesn't pay attention
to these mediums has no idea what's
going on and I'd be willing to bet the
only reason he became he came to the
position where he is now calling it out
is because he kept getting notes from
his publicist saying you're a Nazi today
you're a white supremacist tomorrow and
Bill was probably like what is this what
are you what are they complaining about
why am I getting negative press from all
of these people then he gets half
introduced to what everyone else is
talking about now he's like this is
crazy people are yelling at me for this
stuff if Bill Maher actually paid
attention to a show like this or to the
commentary we've had for the past
several years or even like the low to
Cedars podcast with Carl Benjamin for a
decade he'd be well versed on the modern
culture wars but it's not just that he
doesn't pay attention it's that I think
this is true for most most uh
demographics Generations they care about
their peers I don't pay attention to
what gen X's are paying attention to
Bill Murray's a boomer I think I don't
yeah
seen Billy eilish on his show yet and
Bill Mark that he wouldn't have her most
likely I only know who that is because
of my own kids so there you go yeah Bill
Maher most likely cares about people in
his yeah surrounding demographic which
is nice about what's happening is
because it's like he he emerged from The
Matrix out of that tank of wet goo and
he's like pulling other people out of it
with him like Brian Cranston people that
are like 65 60 year old
normies that are really influential are
friends with Bill so like he's kind of a
tip of a spear for that generation his
new um I saw him in Cranston did an
episode of his new show uh what is it
where they're just hanging out club
random yeah and they're like both like
gently kind of acknowledging the culture
war and like how crazy stuff is as an
aside we're gonna be uh I'm gonna be
launching a new show that's basically
just sitting down and talking to people
that's great dude do you have the are
you gonna publicly announce the
specifics on that we got to figure out
when we're gonna publish it we're going
to record it on Friday mornings because
Friday mornings are just garbage news
days and most people like the rate like
the views are way down people are a lot
less interested I know it's actually
people who like watching the news
segments on Fridays but it's just like
journalists are all checked out and I'm
like it's an opportunity to do a
different show so we have a guest coming
this Friday I believe and it's not going
to be it's gonna be cultural but it's
not going to be like news topics
segmented like we do here talking about
current events it's gonna be just like
open concept what I love about the open
combo is because if that's how you
envelop the spirit of the individual
like that's the real the real coverage
to bring the humanity out of people like
we can talk about what happened and what
might happen but you really want to talk
to someone about who they are man that's
when you see yeah so so to clarify I've
had people say stuff like Tim Castile
Tim's just trying to be like Joe Rogan
and I'm like we pull up the top news
stories of the day and then I have a
timer where we track news story segments
which is a combination of the guests
perspective and our perspective on
current events
what this new show is probably more like
Rogan it's literally just or like Club
random I'm gonna sit down and be like
hey what's up this is who you are let's
have a conversation so it's like
something we don't actually do in full
it's hard for me not to think that
people who say oh this is like Joe we're
going to really watch either one of
those shows they're obviously different
as soon as you watch them it'd be like
saying like all that crime shows like
law order SVU like Tucker Carlson is the
exact same as yeah exactly it's more
like the view get it straight yeah
exactly and I did want to say sorry the
only thing I can say is I just looked it
up while we were talking and Bill Maher
doesn't have any children so what you're
saying like the reason that you know who
this pop singer is is because you have
children the people who keep you alert
to what's going on in your school system
the people who you have to think well
what's in their best interest what what
are their concerns you know some people
and I if you didn't have kids like I'm
not gonna speculate on why but it is
interesting that this coincides with the
push especially for young women not to
have children to say why we got that
crazy list why you know 300 reasons why
you should definitely not have show
children they're bad and even the good
reasons are actually bad you know there
is a push to keep people away from being
connected to Generations as well as to
people within their own Community it's
really sad intergenerational
communication is so key I love internet
video games for that reason why I'm
still tapped into like what a 14 how a
14 year old thinks is I mean I don't
like get down with 14 year olds
intentionally but it's fun to know it's
it's so important if you play a game
like if you play online video games on
PlayStation you just oh man I I like
playing human fall flat you play that
game I've not played that one it's it's
a silly game and you like you're a guy
and you have you can like grab stuff and
you climb up it's just a weird control I
don't know how to describe it you're
just like a little dude trying to like
climb obstacles and make it to the exit
but don't turn on the audio because if
you turn it on all you'll hear is like
10 year olds going
if you want to figure out what the kids
are up to just play Call of Duty and
then you'll get some 12 years I'm
playing Hogwarts Legacy with my teenage
son yeah I'm playing that now but not
getting my teenage son that game's
incredible oh wow good game I like it
yeah I want to ask you about we're gonna
go to super chess pretty soon I want to
ask you about your book The Rise of the
fourth Reich because we've been talking
about covid basically the government
reactions to covid that's what this
book's about correct how do you what is
it about that that you saw that had in
common with the Third Reich which is
Hitler's organization is Nazi
organization so a lot of people know
about the Nuremberg trials that came out
of World War II but there wasn't there
was another aspect of the Nuremberg
trials they held separate trials for
what they described basically as a
biomedical fascist state that
essentially the healthcare sector had
had fused with the state to impose a lot
of the experimentation
um uh and and was categorized as health
care policy and so there was the the the
the Hippocratic Oath um the idea of
human worth and dignity were totally
lost via the healthcare sector so there
was there that was the there was no more
guard rails for anyone to go to for
their Humanity to get recognized once
the state took it away we're going to
say something there today I was going to
ask you about uh I'm just thinking about
what we do with Japan when we brought uh
not not necessarily didn't we bring over
a bunch of their scientists oh you're
thinking of uh we brought over a bunch
of the German scientists paper clip but
there was also something with the
Japanese scientists because we learned a
lot of information from Unit 731 seven
speakers they did things that we never
would say right look ethical to do and I
just took the information anyways and
then now we have all this you know I was
gonna say I wonder if like War stuff if
you're talking about World War one and
I'm like I'm wondering if that typically
is their excuse for experimentation Unit
731 that's the job yeah like and paper
clip but that paperclip was mostly like
what like physics and weapons and stuff
yep yeah and so what we saw here is the
exact same thing Obamacare basically
ended what was left of the individual
patient provider relationship on a
corporate level in much of America you
can still find it people people that are
doctors that are independent you still
go to a place like an integrative Family
Health Clinic in your area and and not
get sick care but actual health care but
by and large corporately Obamacare ended
the patient provider system uh and
you're no longer an individual you're
not treated and now we have we've got
guidelines from CDC this is the code CDC
has the guidelines here's how we treat
you and all of that now was perfectly
set up for when covid came along all of
these ham-fisted policies there is that
we didn't look at anything individual to
look at individual regions because New
York's hospitals are run over Montana's
schools have to be shut down and on and
on and on it went and the fact that they
they were the tip of the spear to impose
all of this they were that you were
never allowed to question any of it the
science was against them from the very
beginning there were and this wasn't a
what I think a lot of people thought
that this was a a substitute for the
global warming debate the a bunch of
right-wingers against scientific
consensus wrong the reality is there
were a eight scientists from Harvard
Yale Stanford Oxford number one rated
University in the world according to U.S
news and World Report that pushed back
against these things from the very
beginning of the Imperial College survey
that shut the world down and yet they
were all ignored they were ignored by
the Trump White House they were ignored
by every every government in the world
and we just went with this ham-fisted
plan instead they never stepped back
when the data showed they were wrong
they showed no humility no empathy they
violated 90 years of science on mass
that we had developed since the Spanish
Flu post World War one we knew they
didn't work against respiratory viruses
that's why you have been wearing masks
every cold and flu season your entire
life they knew all of this and yet they
imposed this power instead why we get
into that in the book and I think what
really sets this book apart from other
attempts that will be made to have a
reckoning of this era okay go ahead I'm
gonna say we I want to make sure we
point out they literally murdered people
yes that first of all they created the
virus guys they created the chimeric
concoction that came out of that lab the
same people that were working on all the
solutions the same kind of elements
within NIH and the in our it's not a
China virus I wish it were just their
virus our scientists were over there
working on this with them how that's not
even in dispute at this point in time
the big issue is how it got out of the
lab and why okay so but in terms of the
that's a good point too we had the uh
there was a study or a paper from the
University of Beijing do you mention
that in the book uh I think it was
University division you want to infected
me on this one where they said that bats
had bitten and peed on people in the
Wuhan Institute of virology and that
could be how the SARS covet 2 may have
gotten out of the lab then abruptly it
was rescinded and they said nope nope
we're wrong about that but I don't want
to deviate what I wanted to bring up was
we can talk about mandates and lockdowns
but they literally killed people and I
want to just make sure yeah we can be
specific about this they took covid
patients and put them in nursing homes
correct with the most vulnerable
population at least five states in at
least five states and why was a 30 year
old being put in a nursing home with
elderly people who are at risk why were
they not was it the Comfort was the ship
in New York
yeah we can make up every argument in
the world about why they decided not to
use the Javit Center why they did not
decided not to put the ships that Trump
sent in uh to use those facilities and
instead took people with covid who
should not be in nursing homes and put
them there yeah we get into the whole
gamut every issue real quick oh yeah
you're right the Beijing sponsored South
China university uh paper that said that
instead of coming out of the seafood
market it was possible that someone had
been had the blood of bat on their skin
and then one of the researchers that had
been attacked by a bat so uh he had
quarantined for 28 days can I address
that really quick because the term gain
of function gets thrown around a lot
and and don't get me wrong gain a
function is is Flirting With Disaster
Molly Hatchet gain a function is is is
lighting up the bikini at all with a
hydrogen bomb to see what what what its
blast radius is
not what they were doing they were doing
something worse
in their own words they did get they did
gain a function to gauge what they
called quote spill over potential these
are their own words that is now the Akin
of not we're not only going to drop a
hydrogen bomb on the bikiniato we're now
going to put a human being in the blast
radius because we want to see what the
radiation does to humans they were
specifically provoking these bat
coronaviruses in the labs to spill over
to human beings they wanted to know they
were poking it provided provoking it
prodding it they specifically wanted to
know what would make it spill over to a
human being that is there's Icarus
flying close to the Sun guys and then
there's Icarus flying up to the sun with
a freaking hydrogen bomb and throwing it
into the sun that's what they were doing
we got to go to super chats but I want
to bring up one last thing did you know
that in 2019 it was reported they were
doing gain of function research on avian
flu to specifically make it
transmissible among mammals and had it
and got the avian flu to infect ferrets
and the question is now why would you go
ahead and make something like that the
avian flu mortality rate is 60 when it
does cross over to humans which is rare
because it's difficult for the virus to
do but why would you do gain of function
to make it so all the answers to that
question are bad well let's let's go to
super chats we'll finish we'll
definitely talk about more of this in
the Amazon let's go super chats before
uh we do make sure you smash that like
button if you haven't already become a
member at timcast.com go to timcast.com
click that join us button we're gonna
have a pretty spicy members only show
coming up not so family friendly and uh
you can follow the show at timcast.com
follow me at timcast let's read what you
guys have to say
Falcon ER Falcon Iraq says huge fan of
both Tim Poole and Steve Dace very cool
thank you support
all right Brandon M says the First Act
of the board of an organization without
O'Keefe whose name means truth is to lie
to everyone
yeah someone someone brought this up uh
last week or whatever James O'Keefe is
the only person accused of malfeasance
by Veritas without without evidence
every single instance where Veritas is
Accused someone of doing something
they've shown the video of them doing it
except James yeah
stupid is that they don't hold
themselves to their own standards it's
crazy
all right correct 57 says Tim what do
you think about Twitter personalities
caught accepting Pac money from Biden
admin I don't know about that what's
that about
anything about it no idea
all right I don't know why the Biden
Administration would pay Twitter
personalities to chill for them because
I just think a lot of people would do it
for nothing out of cultic Devotion to
the agenda frankly yeah but they pay all
the take talkers you know they got to
get the young vote as well there you go
they pay them to push a specific message
right it's like a marketing deal right
yeah all right what do we got here
easy kill says here is my monthly
donation that normally goes to project
Veritas use it well well thank you for
this we need to uh I'm trying to get in
touch with James O'Keefe he is not an
easy man to get in touch with right now
I imagine he's got ndas or something but
I'd like to get in touch with him and uh
so if he hears this to so he can try and
figure out what he's gonna do because
I'm sure whenever he has the chance and
I assume he can launch something quickly
we got to get him in here so he can tell
all of you guys where to direct your
donations to keep the work going
I don't think anybody's got faith in
veritas without a James O'Keefe I don't
and I'm going to say it again James
putting out the music video oligarchy is
one of the reasons I liked project
Veritas James doing the dancing and the
DJ stuff bringing this I always talk
about people Gotta Throw pies like throw
the figuratively throw pie do something
to build culture to to to create
something interesting project Veritas as
these like look I I don't want to
disrespect the journalists who are doing
these interviews but like I don't know
who these people are they're not
charismatic they they mean it means
nothing to me James is like this this
charismatic dude that I have that I
trust shows strength and is interesting
with the like the character that he's
developed for Veritas and the energy and
the Persona of veritas itself so I just
want to say that again
I like the dance show oh you got it
nothing he did you know spending money
on this music video or whatever else
he's accused accused of like losing
money-wise
the journalism kept getting bigger and
better right so if he spent sixty
thousand dollars on a dance party I mean
I think we've made it up in the amount
of truth that he's uncovered yes dad's
cigarette run says watch the video on
your channel and it's heartbreaking
there will be a reckoning so uh we had
anonymous source provides some
information to us pertaining to veritas
so I just there was this it's a video of
James O'Keefe
basically explain what's going on just
uploaded it raw and I was like I don't
know look we're we're planning on doing
this new show probably for probably
recorded Friday and I'm wondering if
maybe we'll we'll upload the
conversational podcast it's gonna be its
own podcast on Apple and Spotify maybe I
don't know Sunday night we're gonna
record it Friday morning but I don't
know if putting up on Friday is the best
thing to do maybe I don't know maybe
just do it there's a lot of room on
Saturday and Sunday for something well
Sundays are good days because people are
at home and they're getting ready and
you know but yeah and Friday's terrible
like Friday night is Just but that's
when I have the real opportunity to
record it
and I don't know maybe we just do it
Friday morning yeah that works I'm
always looking for content on Sundays
honestly so yeah Sunday's a good day for
release but for your schedule I'm
thinking we're gonna we're gonna we're
gonna record at 10 10 to noon on Fridays
maybe we just upload it right away right
after the show it goes up at one on a
Friday or something it is what it is
yeah but anyway anyway I digress yeah so
uh I I just put it up on the channel
because I didn't know where else to put
it I was like we want to publish it we
want people to see what James has to say
if anyone's following along Veritas
Twitter accounts lost 22 000 followers
since we've been talking so now it's at
155. yeah 157.5 I still follow him so so
far I mean I want to see what they're
saying yeah that's the hard thing there
are some people that want to be able to
get the updates from Project Veritas I
wanted more companies like Veritas
anyway so maybe this is just the hard
way to make that happen I can't imagine
project Veritas without James O'Keefe
yeah it doesn't make sense what are they
gonna I don't know I I have a feeling
that James O'Keefe simply comes out and
announces he's launching you know uh the
the truth operation and instantly is
making 10 million a year hires a staff
and the next video we see if a big
expose comes from them and not Veritas
you know how there are some companies
where one person does it
jobs when they leave it's very difficult
to replace them like not only does James
have this public Persona people send him
information he is involved in the
administrative day to day he's involved
in his own reporting like it would be so
difficult to replace him and it's easy
for him to maintain uh all of the skills
that he has and just start something new
well so you know I just got to say James
you know come on the show and then uh
figure out the new the new organization
and we'll uh we'll do a whole show so as
soon as he gets that ready we'll we'll
have him here and we'll figure it out
yeah I guess what they said like he was
packing up his stuff or something is
that what they said in the in their
statement I imagine half the employees
are going to leave and join his new
company if he does that I would imagine
probably a bunch of them would Ryan
Ellis says the purpose of James getting
the boot is to destroy Veritas they
don't care if they lose followers they
want it to crash and burn yeah there you
go no he's not a why like what is it oh
come on not your own organized I mean
the Epstein stuff no no but like I mean
the Epstein stuff but like he's been
going for a while right like it's hard
for me not to think that there is
something that he wanted to do that the
board was like no we're not willing to
look at that I don't know I think James
gets so freaked out because he was
putting his life on the line and he's
like do what I say no no no no no no no
no no no I got to stop you the FBI
raided the home of of James and his uh
he was in his underwear or something and
like other employees this this they have
been trying to shut down Veritas it just
seems they figured out how to do it
maybe they went to a board member and
said you know what going after James
isn't working we'll go after you and
then the board members are like
I'm not dealing with this get James out
of here I'd rather not deal with it
so I I whenever
complete and utter stupidity
is though is the most benign and
innocent explanation
rest assured
every other potential option is far
worse than that
so this is either just mind-numbing
stupidity
that even if he is guilty of everything
you're accusing him of that you would
choose now with the organization at its
Pinnacle of influence and success to
absolutely kneecap and decapitate it
that that that you that's either the the
issue all these people just got this
instantaneously stupid rather than
handle this stuff privately or
fill in the blank Randall Hogan says Tim
you need to hire James to run timcast
News James O'Keefe does not need I do
not think he needs
my help on anything or I would also say
I don't know if I could afford to hire
James O'Keefe I mean pretty comes a lot
of legal fees a lot of legal fees and
his salary is publicly known you know
because it's a non-profit they disclose
what his salary is but more importantly
James has the talent uh work ethic and
wherewithal to Simply snap his fingers
to create a new organization and with
all the experiences gained probably get
it up and running within less half a
year and then instantly with his friends
and allies in in the space have more
than enough donors to be right back to
where he was and maybe a bump in the
road but nobody needs to hire James
James is probably just going to moonwalk
his way into a new organization with a
new name and it'll be bigger and better
than ever I recommend a private
for-profit Corporation I don't think
anyone who don't to Veritas is concerned
about how James is let me put this way
James leaving effectively ending Veritas
and everyone's like that he is Veritas
I'm willing to bet every person who has
given James O'Keefe money if James said
to his donors guys my boat is broken and
I work too much the only way I can get
it fixed if I fly in a private Charter
here's how much we've brought in does
anyone care if I spend 14 000 on this I
bet 98 or 100 would be like James you
deserve this man the risks you've taken
the work you've done that the positive
impact you've had on society take a
private jet if he had a for-profit
company nobody would bet an eye they'd
be like that's his own company he makes
the money he can do what he wants but he
does the right thing starts a non-profit
takes a smaller salary than he than he
than he would have if he was in a
for-profit and then now he's being
accused of and not to mention also of
his lies I just don't I'm not going to
believe it sorry they said he was
abusing employees then when that is
disproven and the donor two donors come
out and they're like that never happened
those are lies now it's well he was
spending money he wasn't supposed to
spend yeah okay spare me anyway
all right Matthew Evans says if only we
knew someone who was starting a
nonprofit that James could pivot to if
only it could be named Ministry of truth
that's a good idea it's very snarky I
like that yeah that's good Ministry of
Truth uh I think I I have to imagine
right now James is talking to like a
corporate attorney about setting up a
new nonprofit right now the thing about
nonprofits is you have to have board
members
you have to I know it's annoying it's
it's both the strength and the weakness
of it because you can't start without
having three people in charge which
means two of them can throw you out at
any moment if you're one of the three
you really gotta trust the people you
work with have a vision for the future
and I don't know just pray that the
thing works it's weird to think that you
can spend three years building something
and then your two managing Partners can
just decide you're out I don't know if
they can do it without just cause I
don't know if that works but you know
it's so a lot of people are mentioning
like I should hire James or start
something with him and I'm just kind of
like James needs to be the sole owner
CEO 100 board member all of that stuff
of his own for-profit Corporation and
then he can come on this show anytime he
wants when he wants to shout it out and
build up a membership base to help fund
his work and and as I mentioned earlier
in the show he should do he uh the legal
fees are probably the the most difficult
thing for these guys but he should do
the normal work they're doing and then
offer a project Veritas commentary
behind the scenes for paying members so
sign up for 10 20 bucks a month support
Veritas for profit not tax deductible
but then you can listen to James talk
about the story in a more candid you
know fashion that he records like once a
week or with every story and I think
it's a way to do it then you can spend
the money on whatever he wants not that
I think he's wasting it and I think it
just it protects him no no board nobody
can fire him nobody can boot him he
never has to worry about this like how
did he get fired he is Veritas that's
just insane to me it should be possible
all right all right
because reason says James gave us an
emotional speech it makes me think while
he is getting in his car and driving
away he ain't done yet no way he is a
fighter I mean what if the next video we
see of James is him just like sitting on
the beach with like a coconut and he's
just like I'm done I'm retired I started
something I'm done what if the first
video of his new organization is
of one of these board members that's
what I was wondering yeah
oh man if he'll have no fury like a
muckrack or scorn guys imagine being one
of these board members right now having
to go into a meeting with project
Veritas and they're gonna be like is
anybody wearing the lapel mics anybody
with the cameras I would urge every
member of that board
there if you
they're way too hot for you beware yes
I'd have to imagine the only way the
board can actually meet with Veritas
employees right now is to make them all
wear like unitards
everybody has to here's your new uniform
when you're in the building yes
they get them it makes me wonder also
like they've been working with James for
years like what does he already know
about them that that for he would have
kept to himself that now he doesn't have
to right like unless they got him to
sign a non-disparagement agreement which
I really doubt they are completely
vulnerable to him
he's got to start a non-profit in West
Virginia he's got to come down here
come down to West Virginia yeah not New
York New York's bad yeah all right New
York's a terrible idea if you want to be
a non-profit or at least conservative
non-profit all right wrath says Tim AP
News roughly 30 minutes ago so this is
about 8 8 P.M Ohio metal plant Up Up in
Flames several people injured don't know
if it's relevant wow
strands says two dozen eggs cost me
12.48 cents today 40 pounds of chicken
feed 13.50 Blue Sapphire chickens will
be shipped tomorrow man
1250 is this the most expensive eggs
I've ever been in human history
I try to over the weekend but
I think prices that are relatively
inexpense like it's hard on human
history right
I think in the last four decades from
the church I saw I don't know about him
in history four decades maybe but like
during famine or whatever you know if
you had a couple eggs probably very
expensive but I think also more people
had chickens right we yeah during times
of famine correct people had their own
livestock and ways of families I think
until what like the 1900s every family
had a cow like at least one cow it was
like a normal thing yeah like you had to
go but then you can't take it with you
to your apartment in your you know large
city so that went away man and then we
got too many eggs too many yeah because
we got a chicken City I was watching a
documentary about the Middle Ages they
all had a pig not everybody pretty much
everybody had a pig and you'd have to
turn them out onto the street at night
and they just root through and there was
just pigs all over the place this is
something that didn't get a lot of media
attention I think that people have a
deep-seated hatred for pigs because of
the way that the wild boars would hide
in the bushes and ambush people Gore
them and then eat them alive oh and so
they say they're like dirty yeah we I
mean there's such a hate we don't have
it for dogs we don't we don't call and
eat dogs we do it with pigs they're just
as smart or essentially they're about
yeah but I think it's because of this
deep-rooted hatred of the wild boar so
we're like you know what you've deserved
this for hundreds of thousands of years
you've terrorized my species now we're
gonna eat you alive I think they're just
delicious you know like they certainly
have become that way it could possibly
be that bacon happens to taste very good
I'm a fan of pig so yes I think pigs are
very good I think I think uh bacon is
universally beloved yeah I've even had
vegans tell me that you know the the
activist vegan saying they miss bacon
not all of them you know I'm not trying
to accuse all vegans of liking meat but
the activists vegans have had people be
like yeah yeah that's why they buy fake
bacon the the idea that vegan meat
exists shows that these people are
unhappy with their choices all right I'm
just ragging on vegans now no you you're
all right vegans you can eat whatever
you want but I will point out that
there's that famous video of when the
hurricane was coming and the whole store
is cleared out but the vegan section is
completely full yeah like nobody wanted
to buy any of that stuff it's too salty
man yeah the impossible Burger has more
salt than a McDonald's burger McDonald's
Burger's got too much salt in it as it
is I think when veganism got trendy
people thought it was code for healthy
and it's not like you can eat pasta with
olive oil on it all day long and be a
vegan and not be healthy at all yeah
sugar is vegan yeah Oreos it's the
overeating of meat and sugar that is
what's the it's the overeating
generally yeah overeating in general of
anything is bad although there is a lot
of sugar in what we're eating now have
you seen those videos about like back in
the day people used to consume like half
a pound of sugar I should find the video
and quote it more accurately there's a
funny advertisement when they were
marketing sugar and it was like low
calorie energy bursts it was a woman
eating a spoonful of sugar it's wild
I've seen that and it was like for a low
calorie burst of energy and I'm like
that's the craziest idea that don't do
that they have those sugar cubes they'd
be like how many one or two and they'd
put these giant cubes of sugar in the
tea yeah that's crazy I think they still
do that we have a in Iowa we have a
place called living history farms where
you can go back to The Agrarian more
agrarian time in America and you can
actually do like theme dinners and uh
one of the I went my wife and I went uh
with some couples several years ago to
what was dinner in Iowa was like for a
family in like 1911 because it was just
2011 so 100 you know and it was a I
could not believe by the way the amount
of carbs they consumed I could not
believe the amount of calories they
consumed and absolutely one of the
palette cleansers in between meals was a
thing of sugar cubes okay and so as
someone who over the years has lost like
over 100 pounds like I'm like really
cognizant of the amount of food there
there that I get served now you know and
and I remember asking the attendant how
did all these people ate this much food
and yet man like size 36 genes would
have been considered chubby to them
right like I had to lose 100 pounds to
fit into a size 36 Gene and she said to
me well they also worked out in the
fields for nine hours a day and burned
all those calories off they their jobs
weren't sedentary okay there was this
study that came out that said that uh
our average body temperature has gone
down by a degree because we are less
active as a whole right more employment
is sedentary so you spend more time
sitting on we are seeing the effects of
the shifts in our economic lifestyle
like I don't necessarily want to work in
a field I I mean that's why you saw
Michael Phelps and he was swimming was
doing five thousand per person 8 000
calories per day or something yeah uh
when I was skating at my Max I was
probably doing five to eight thousand
calories a day and a lot of people don't
believe me but I'm like no like
seriously like whole pizzas to myself
yeah skating for like eight to ten hours
a day drenched in sweat all day non-stop
like yeah it was brutal I dated this
girl we ran marathons and she we would
eat giant she'd make giant pasta meals
and then eat it and then just be super
thin like a and I'm like I couldn't eat
I couldn't couldn't do it dude I would I
would wake up in the morning and we'd go
grab like some fast food I get like two
burgers two nuggets we would go skate
like crazy then I would get like a a
Panda Express three entree meal then we
would go back and at night have like a
whole pizza it's like I would go to the
skate park and skate for eight to ten
hours
just non-stop drenched in sweat the next
day I would be able to walk like I would
just be paralyzed from like my muscles
just tightening up and I couldn't move
yeah I knew I know I have a family
friend whose sons are both very elite
baseball players one plays in college
one plays in high school and she used to
tell me that especially when they were
going through puberty and both of these
guys are like six foot five six foot
seven they're huge she used to just like
get pounds of ground turkey and like
keep it like cook it for them and they
would just eat it all the time because
they were constantly hungry one of them
went to boarding school and you know he
so there's a cafeteria dining hall and
he didn't have access to food all the
time and he lost like 30 pounds because
he was just this huge athlete who needed
calories I mean that's the closest we
have to this time period that you're
talking about when they were uh there's
much more physical labor also you walked
more places to get around like yeah
people also also really underestimate
how many cat how much calories they are
eating like when they started adding the
adding the calorie counter to like menus
and stuff at a fast food restaurant and
you're like you mean a burger and fries
is 1500 calories what though yeah so
imagine if you did three times a day you
had five thousand calories crazy does do
people you know 4 500 do different
people produce different amounts of
calories from the same food like if you
eat a piece of broccoli I eat the exact
same piece would would one of our bodies
make more heat yes so then so it's the
calorie numbers not in the food it's
it's a result of our body calorie is a
representation of uh energy required to
to burn or something like that but burn
the food but the issue is uh to clarify
what your question is if you take the
same piece of food and two people like
exact replicas and two people eat it
their bodies will handle it differently
and there is no way it could be equal in
the energy output so that's why the
calories not in the food that's that's
important to keep in mind not super
important someone who is six foot five
220 pounds muscle is given a cupcake
someone who is 90 pound a 90 pound
female who does an exercise given the
same cup the same exact cupcake that the
body is going to use them in very
different ways like that the output will
probably be very different
so like and actually a better example
might be like uh a steak where you've
got a lot of protein the body's got to
break down very hard on the liver and
some or something like that a dude is
gonna probably rip through that thing
way better than someone who's not
working out or sedentary so you're not
not only that but I mean like somebody
who's morbidly obese and doesn't
exercise who's given a cupcake is gonna
have a blood sugar Spike and probably
feel really really sick an athlete will
probably just not even notice
probably maybe feel sick later I mean
bad food is bad you know garbage and
garbage out anyway all right let's read
some more of these super chats OMG
puppies says Jehovah's Witnesses and
Adventists believe the Earth will be
restored to the Garden of Eden and the
saved will live there the 144 000 are a
special group who go to heaven so they
go they want you to live in the Garden
of Eden you can't go to heaven though
sorry it's not for you
I prefer the biblical worldview where
Jesus offers all of his followers Heaven
not just 144. let's get to that number I
don't understand it's a symbolic number
in the Book of Revelation ah
all right what do we got Ted Mahoney
says National divorce would reduce the
remaining states to Global
insignificance and we would be dissected
and ruled by other superpowers
agreed
yep
Mark gordetti says Real Americans want
to fix the union not run away from it
like cowards but that would require
Federal intervention to California which
probably would result in I don't know
Civil War unless California rolls over
but so long as California is violating
the Constitution and subverting the
federal government what more can we do
the social compact is dead
there is no social compact in America
anymore and
and that that really is the the the
underlying Foundation of a constitution
what a constitution does is it is it
codifies that social compact it it it it
it takes the shared values and itemizes
them and enumerates them in a legal
document the social compact is the
essence of what a constitution
enumerates and that is gone and and so
California has no problems whatsoever
um about about being a platform to
eradicate your way of life in fact it is
proud of doing so and it is
affirmatively it's not it's it's not an
accident it's it's it's missional
they're doing it on purpose the the only
way you're going to hold the union
together
outside of civil war or Revival
is you're going to have to have more
Governors do what DeSantis has done in
Florida
militant forms of federalism and
interposition
uh the the doctrine of interposition of
the Lesser magistrate that's what the
founders wanted state and local
governments to do is is the people you
elected on a state and local level
juries were a form of interposition they
called them the fourth branch of
government
um that so right down to to 12 peers on
a local jury you could interpose of
Washington if the federal government
went off the rails these other layers
could stand in and say no you don't get
to impose that upon my people we won't
enforce that here we will not impose
that on them here we won't adjudicate
that here we will practice uh through
the doctrine of the Lesser magistrate
forms of interposition you have to and
and they've done that to us when Donald
Trump got elected in 2000 when John When
Donald Trump took office in January of
2017. there were fewer elected Democrats
in office in America than there had been
since before the Great Depression before
FDR's New Deal created the modern
democratic Coalition and yet did San
Francisco say ah snap
Republicans have total control of the
White House and uh orange man bad as
president we're going to stop doing
subsidies for Trans homeless people in
San Francisco now because the the other
sides and did they change San Francisco
change anything they were doing no they
just San Francisco Don that's an example
of interposition that's a good Fitness
kept on San Francisco didn't care what
the hell orange man bad was saying from
the White House can we can we just write
a San Francisco San Francisco that
should that's the verb for doing you
know failed policy yes insane things but
we need West Virginia your state we're
not a Democrat hasn't won your pre a
Precinct in your state since the 08
presidential election yeah Mansions
gonna switch parties but but we need
West Virginia to be as red as California
as blue it's not my state of Iowa's
rather than yours Texas needs to Texas
needs to be redder than Florida
Mississippi look at Wyoming but do you
know how close West Virginia is to D.C
well I understand and and you've got
Frederick and then you've got the
college town ones and you've got but
you're still in a state where Democrats
haven't won in a presidential election a
Precinct since 2000 not a county a
freaking Precinct we need but Iowa is
historically red right no West Virginia
is not no until uh Bush in 2004 uh was
the only Republican since Reagan 84 that
won our state in a presidential election
until Trump
and it's traditionally been a very
purple State we need Mississippi Alabama
those States need to actually earn their
reputations the red states are not as
red as the hard blue states are blue and
that's what's killing us more than
anything else if we had more
interposition more of essentially
de-escalating what they try to do to us
from Washington that would give us much
more of a chance than what we have right
now all right Abel says I have never
heard of Steve before tonight's show but
he has a new follower also Hannah Claire
and Ian look like they could be related
just an opinion oh they actually are
yeah long lost uh cousins they're just
generalizing white people right now I
don't like that you guys all look the
same yeah well you know I am I a lot and
under the rules of wokeness am I allowed
like how much of a not of how much not
white do you have to be before you know
I I think surge is because he's
African-American yeah yeah yeah
your mic's off yeah I let her say off
people told me I should stop talking but
yeah it's technicality
that but what do you mean literally
you're
South African I mean uh literally I am
African-American so didn't you practice
who you are I don't understand what's
happening Dylan Elon Musk say something
about that like being an
African-American someone said about him
like they're they're being mean to like
the African-American Tech entrepreneur
entrepreneur Elon Musk there's a uh
there's like a famous story where there
was a grant for African-American
scholarship or something and a
blonde-haired white kid showed up and
they were like what is this he's like
I'm from South Africa no but I guess
like he genuinely didn't know yeah he
because he was like we don't have that
phrase where I come from so it said
African-American I was like oh I'm from
Africa and I came here and then they got
mad at me I know it never made sense to
me actually it was just this yeah like
Caucasian from the Caucasus region the
best is I'm from I'm not from there the
best when I was in university I went to
school with the guy from uh Britain who
was from Jamaica's mother from like
Saint Lucia and everyone call them
African-American like I'm not American
yeah what are you saying like I know a
guy who is uh not an American citizen
and uh this is a long time ago at a
different job I had and uh we were
talking about Caucasian African-American
Pacific what do these things mean and
then this guy got really mad he's like I
am not African-American I am from Haiti
and he was like he wasn't even an
American citizen you know he had like a
work visa and he was Haitian and he was
like call me Haitian man yeah seriously
just calling him African
anyway all right let's see we got here
Thomas side bottom says I hate the
argument I usually get from lefties that
religion Christianity is a cult Cults
remove you from your family and support
structure Christianity helps you develop
a better bond with them right that's a
that's a really good distinction a key
component of Cults is to isolate you
from family and and friends to to keep
you away from anyone who might oppose
what they think whereas not even just
Christianity but a lot of these are very
internally family oriented like Judaism
for instance with with uh Shabbat it's
like be with your family talk to those
you love and care about so well the The
Cult of the spirit of the age is doing
that now it's just doing it in terms of
uh you are separated from your family
into the new woke religion and you you
should separate yourself from anybody
that might have different viewpoints
rather than debate them discuss with
them or even try to defeat them in the
arena of ideas they're automatically a
lesser form of human racist misogynistic
xenophobic homophobic bigot so they're
they're the other and and should not be
uh considered for uh polite viewing or
for debate whatsoever we are going to
head over to uh we're gonna go record
the members only show so go to
timcast.com and sign lineup click that
join us button because we're going to
talk about the rise of the fourth Reich
and biomedical tyranny and a lot of
stuff like that it's gonna be really
interesting so again smash that like
button subscribe to the show share this
show with your friends and become a
member at timcast.com you can follow the
show at timcastirl you can follow me
personally at timcast Steve do you want
to shout anything out
you've got great hardwood floors
downstairs man
really I I'm really impressed yeah some
of the nicest hardwood floors I've ever
seen really yeah I don't think they're
that good I mean really nice yeah I was
really impressed wait to see the new
wait till you see the new studio we uh
we filmed the music video there at the
new space and it's like it's getting
there it's it's getting there the studio
room is mostly done we could probably
start setting up studio equipment there
now yeah probably because the room
itself is I think it's done and the
green room is getting worked on I'm
really excited we just need to get it
done ASAP but yeah thank you for
shouting out of course and you can if
you want if you liked what I had to say
here tonight uh sign up for the podcast
just like for Steve Day show on iTunes
Stitcher Spotify Amazon all that stuff
right on uh I'm Hector I'm a writer for
timcast.com Steve this has been great uh
you should follow at timcast news on
Twitter and on Instagram it's the best
new site in my opinion uh you follow me
personally on Instagram at hannahclar.b
and you can follow me on Twitter at HC
brimlow also if you know where I can get
more knit American flag sweaters I'd
like to add some more to my collection
that would be cool but they have to be
knit not just printed thank you have a
good night everyone Ian Crossland Ian
crossland.net follow me anywhere online
at Ian Crossland happy to be here Steve
good to see you you bet just to shout it
out again man nefarious your movies
coming out April 14th who is
nefarious.com all right and uh rise on
the fourth Reich your book we'll be
talking about that later tonight all
right man we'll have that up in about an
hour
and I am at survey.com on Twitter talk
to me there
and we're also uh exploring doing the
members only segments live immediately
following the show so we just gotta work
out the the workflow to get it going but
for today we'll just record it and then
maybe within this week or next week
we'll figure out how to do it live if we
can so anyway we'll see you all over at
timcast.com on the home page in about
one hour you'll see the uncensored
members only we'll see you there thanks
for hanging out